What's better than a well-marbled ribby sizzling on the barbecue? A well-marbled ribby sizzling on the barbecue that was carefully selected by an Instacart shopper and delivered to your door. A well-marbled ribby you ordered without even leaving the kitty pool. Whatever groceries your summer calls for, Instacart has you covered. Download the Instacart app and enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. Hello, everybody.
还有什么比在烤架上滋滋作响、纹理漂亮的肋眼牛排更诱人的呢？那就是由Instacart采购专员精心挑选并送到您门前、在烤架上滋滋作响的肋眼牛排。是一块您甚至不用离开儿童戏水池就能下单的肋眼牛排。无论您夏天需要采购什么杂货，Instacart都能满足您的需求。下载Instacart应用，前三单即可享受0美元配送费。服务费、排除条款和适用条件均适用。Instacart，为您超预期配送杂货。大家好。
Hi there. So I am still in Chicago. I'm still doing my play. And I'm going to be here a little bit longer because we just found out that my play, Ashland Avenue, has been extended again to October 19th. So if you haven't had a chance to see it, please come see it. Oh, it's crazy. I've had the best time. It has been such a joy to watch you on this journey, lady.
大家好。我目前还在芝加哥。我还在演我的话剧。我要在这里多呆一会儿，因为我们刚得知我的话剧《阿什兰大道》再次延长上演至10月19日。所以如果你还没机会看，请务必来看。哦，这太疯狂了。我度过了最美好的时光。看你在这次旅程中成长真是太高兴了，女士。
Oh my gosh. I can't believe it. Every night I go out there and, you know, sometimes we have two shows a day. I just can't wait to do these scenes. I just love them. It's like I look forward to each scene for a different reason. There's like some moment that one of the other actors, I can't wait to watch them do it. Isn't that so fun to just get to watch and marvel at your co-stars like moment? Yes. Oh my gosh. The actor who plays my dad, Fran Geinen, I am constantly marveling at him. I just, You know, the other woman in the play with me, her name is Cordelia Dudney, and she is so good. And we only get one scene together. It's only like three pages. It's short, but it's so good. It's, oh, I look forward to it every night. I can't wait. As soon as she walks in the door, I'm like, yes, here we go.
哦天哪。我真不敢相信。每天晚上我走上舞台，你知道的，有时我们一天演两场。我简直等不及要演这些对手戏了。我太喜欢了。就像我对每一场戏都有不同的期待原因一样。总会有某个时刻，其他演员的表演让我迫不及待地想看。看着并惊叹于你的联合主演在某个瞬间的表演，是不是很有趣？是的。哦天哪。扮演我爸爸的演员弗兰·盖宁，我一直在为他惊叹。我只是，你知道，剧里和我一起的另一位女演员，她叫科迪莉亚·杜德尼，她太棒了。我们只有一场对手戏。只有大约三页纸。很短，但非常精彩。哦，我每天晚上都很期待。我等不及了。她一进门，我就想，太好了，我们开始吧。
Here we go. Yes. Also, you saw the show. You saw how funny Cheeky Johnson is. He plays my husband, Mike, in the play. Can you believe that before this play, he said he doesn't, he doesn't really do comedies. He does dramas, mostly dramas. I was like, what?
我们开始吧。是的。另外，你也看过这个演出。你看到奇基·约翰逊有多搞笑了。他在剧中扮演我的丈夫迈克。你敢相信在这部戏之前，他说他其实不怎么演喜剧吗？他演正剧，大部分是正剧。当时我就想，什么？
What? No, wait, he's so hilarious in the play. He is so funny. He gets the biggest laughs in the play. And we have this really funny scene together. I look forward to it every night. It's an act too. I love it so much.
什么？不，等等，他在剧里太搞笑了。他太逗了。他在剧里赢得了最多的笑声。我们有一场非常搞笑的对手戏。我每天晚上都很期待。那是第二幕。我太喜欢了。
I lived all of your scenes together. You guys have such fun chemistry, and I cannot believe he doesn't normally do comedies. He's so funny. And Angela, we didn't talk about this on our Friday chit-chat a while back, Will Allen, who's another actor in the play, he is an office trivia champion. We have to have him on the podcast lady. Yeah, you know, I met him when I came to see your play, and he told me he paid his rent
我生活在你们所有的对手戏里。你们俩的化学反应太有趣了，我真不敢相信他平时不演喜剧。他太搞笑了。而且安吉拉，我们在之前周五的闲聊中没聊过这个，威廉·艾伦，剧里的另一位演员，他是办公室琐事问答冠军。我们必须请他上我们的播客，女士。是的，你知道，我去你的剧组看演出时遇到了他，他告诉我他靠赢得办公室琐事问答来付房租
by winning office trivia quizzes. Yes, during the pandemic. That's right. And his team, they won the national online competition twice, and they're like the number one team in Chicago. Do you know what their name is? It's an office deep cut. What is it? I'm guessing. Is it? Is it an office reference? It is. What is it? Who's your worm guy? Oh, nice. It's a creed line. That's perfect. That's pretty great, right? Oh, that's so great. Well, lady, while you're doing your play, I'm gearing up for my cookbook tour. Oh my gosh, you're leaving so soon. It's happening. It's happening. We got the book. We got to hold it. It's beautiful. I'm so proud of it. And I can't wait to meet people and just, you know, get our cookbook out in the world. You're going out to sign cookbooks. Tell people where you're going. You're going
在疫情期间。没错。而且他们的团队两次赢得全国在线比赛，他们就像是芝加哥排名第一的团队。你知道他们的队名是什么吗？这是一个《办公室》的深层梗。是什么？我猜。是吗？这是一个《办公室》的梗吗？是的。是什么？谁是你的蠕虫专家？哦，太好了。这是克里德的一句台词。太完美了。这挺棒的，对吧？哦，太棒了。好吧，女士，当你演话剧时，我正在为我的食谱巡回签售做准备。哦天哪，你要走得这么早。要发生了。要发生了。我们拿到书了。我们得拿着它。它太漂亮了。我为它感到骄傲。我迫不及待地想见见大家，把我们的食谱带给全世界。你要出去签售食谱。告诉大家你要去哪。你要去
to three cities, right? We're going to three cities so far, and I'll put all this in our stories, but we are going to New Jersey. We're going to Dallas, and we are going to Santa Monica. And also, we're going to be in New York. We're going to be doing a little fun pop-up things in New York City, like the Today Show, the Sherry Show. I think we're doing some Man on the Street stuff. Man on the street. I have no idea. I know in New York. You and Josh running around? Yeah, I mean, it's going to be an adventure for sure. But the book is great and I can't wait for people to get it. You know what I just realized? This is the year that we both got to bring projects to the world with our husbands. Yeah. How cool is that? Really cool. And so special. It's really special. It's really special, right? Because it's like, here's the love of your life and now you've made something together and you're putting it out in the world. You have like this creative thing that you created together. It's so cool.
三个城市，对吧？到目前为止我们要去三个城市，我会把这些都发到我们的动态里，但我们要去新泽西。我们要去达拉斯，还要去圣莫尼卡。而且，我们还要去纽约。我们将在纽约市做一些有趣的快闪活动，比如《今日秀》、《秀瑞秀》。我想我们还要做一些街头采访。街头采访。我不知道。我知道在纽约。你和乔什到处跑？是的，我的意思是这肯定是一次冒险。但这本书很棒，我等不及让大家看到了。你知道我刚意识到什么吗？今年是我们俩和丈夫一起把项目带给世界的一年。对啊。这有多酷？真的很酷。而且非常特别。真的非常特别。真的很特别，对吧？因为就像是，这就是你一生的挚爱，现在你们一起创造了一些东西，并把它呈献给世界。你们拥有了一起创作的创意结晶。太酷了。
Yeah. You know, Lady, New Year's Rev premiered at the Toronto Film Festival. I know. And it's, oh, huge, amazing reception. Like, people love this movie. People love it. I can't wait until we can announce when this movie is coming out because people love it. I just saw a critic, like a little blurb, and I'm going to paraphrase this, but they had seen the movie and they said something like Green Day has made the next big teen or great teen movie. Something like that. I mean, it's amazing. I'm so proud to be in it. It's so cool. Oh, my gosh, listen to us. Okay. Okay. Sorry. Everybody, we're excited about the stuff we're doing. And that's great, right? It's good to be excited about the stuff you're doing in life, I think, especially if you're an artist. That's what we do. Yeah, absolutely. And, you know, we're also behind the scenes working on new episodes for Office Ladies that are so fun. And this week, we're going to run our appearance on another Odyssey podcast, The Golden Girls Deep Dive. It's hosted by Patrick Hines and Jennifer Samard.
是的。你知道，女士，《新年狂欢》在多伦多电影节首映了。我知道。而且，反响巨大，好极了。人们太喜欢这部电影了。人们太爱它了。我等不及我们可以宣布这部电影什么时候上映了，因为大家太喜欢了。我刚刚看到一位评论家的简短评论，我要意译一下，他们看过电影后说绿日乐队拍出了下一部伟大的青少年电影。诸如此类的话。我的意思是，太棒了。我为能参演感到无比骄傲。太酷了。哦，天哪，听听我们俩。好吧。好吧。抱歉。大家，我们对我们正在做的事情感到兴奋。这很好，对吧？对生活中的事物感到兴奋是一件好事，我认为，特别是如果你是一个艺术家。这就是我们所做的。是的，绝对的。而且，你知道，我们也在幕后为《办公室女士》制作非常有趣的全新剧集。本周，我们将重播我们在另一个Odyssey播客《黄金女郎深度解析》上的亮相。由帕特里克·海恩斯和詹妮弗·萨马德主持。
two are so funny. Every week, they break down an episode of the Golden Girls. They do a really great job back in June. They had us on their podcast for an interview. We had the best time. They asked us to watch an episode of Golden Girls. We don't do like a full breakdown of it, but we do discuss it. Lady, it was so crazy to revisit that show. It makes me want to rewatch the whole show. I mean, it's so good. That's what surprised me, I think. And we kind of talk about this in our interview with them was like how good it was. So good. The nuance and the performances and the comedy. It was so, so good. You know, when we were prepping to do it, I read this article in Southern Living Magazine that has the 65 Best Golden Girls quotes and reading them, Jenna, it made me laugh out loud. Just reading
这两个人太有趣了。每周他们都会剖析一集《黄金女郎》。他们在六月份做得非常棒。他们邀请我们去他们的播客做访谈。我们度过了最美好的时光。他们让我们看了一集《黄金女郎》。我们没有对其进行全面的剖析，但我们进行了讨论。女士，重温那部剧真是太疯狂了。这让我想重新看完整部剧。我的意思是，太棒了。我想这就是让我惊讶的地方。我们在与他们的采访中也谈到了这一点，那就是它有多好。太棒了。细腻度、表演和喜剧效果。真是太棒太棒了。你知道，当我们准备做这件事时，我读了《南方生活》杂志上的一篇文章，上面有65句最佳《黄金女郎》金句，读着它们，珍娜，我忍不住笑出了声。光是读
the quotes. Oh my gosh. Is it sort of like reading a bunch of Joe Bennett quotes? Yes, it is. Okay, here's one. I'll just read you one because there's 65. Dorothy, this is a quote from Dorothy, go to sleep, sweetheart, pray for brains. This is what I'm saying. That feels like something maybe Joe Bennett would say. I feel like Dorothy and Joe Bennett maybe have the same book of quotes. Yeah. Well, lady, I sent you a quiz because I thought we should find out which golden girl we are. Yes, you know, I can share both of these articles in our stories because they made me laugh and I think they're going to make you crack up too. But this quiz was great. And Jen, I'm really curious to hear who you got.
这些金句。哦天哪。这有点像读一堆乔·贝内特的台词吗？是的，确实是。好吧，这里有一句。我只读一句给你听，因为有65句呢。多萝西，这是多萝西的一句台词，去睡觉吧，亲爱的，祈求上帝赐予你大脑吧。这就是我想说的。这感觉像是乔·贝内特可能会说的话。我觉得多萝西和乔·贝内特可能拥有同一本金句集。是的。好吧，女士，我给你发了一个小测试，因为我觉得我们应该找出我们究竟是哪个黄金女郎。是的，你知道，我可以在我们的动态里分享这两篇文章，因为它们让我大笑，我想也会让你捧腹大笑。但这个测试太棒了，珍娜，我真的很想知道你测出来是谁。
Who do you think I was? I think you might think I'm Dorothy. I think you are Dorothy. I was Rose. Oh, my gosh. You were Rose? I guess. I don't know. I answered all the questions and I got Rose. Who do you think I got? Rose. Yes. We're two roses. I think we are. I think we're two. people who just, like, have a lot of fun in life and, like, I don't know. Maybe we, all the ways we don't understand modern technology make us rose. I don't know. That's probably true. Although there were one or two questions that I felt like I was kind of teetering on that I feel
你觉得我是谁？我想你可能会觉得我是多萝西。我觉得你是多萝西。我是露丝。哦，天哪。你是露丝？我猜的。我不知道。我回答了所有问题，然后结果是露丝。你觉得我测出来是谁？露丝。是的。我们是两个露丝。我想是的。我想我们俩都是那种在生活中充满乐趣的人，而且，我不知道。也许我们对现代科技的不理解让我们成了露丝。我不知道。这可能说得对。虽然有一两个问题让我觉得我有点摇摆不定，我觉得
like could have made me a Dorothy. Same. Same. I think though, I'm not a blanche. I think we're Rose with the side of Dorothy. There it is. Oh, well, everyone, I hope you enjoy listening to this interview, you know, since we have both been so busy with some of our other projects, we leaned on some of our friends and other podcasts to interview us, and then we get to share it with you. So we really hope you enjoy it. Have a great week. At long last, I get to say the words, hello, Mother Cheesecake. Hello, Papa. Oh, we're so happy. You are so beautiful. You are glowing. You are radiant. You are the moment. You are the icon. I'm so happy to be back in the studio with you. I have missed you and
可能会让我成为多萝西。我也是。我也是。不过我认为，我不是布兰奇。我觉得我们是带有少许多萝西特质的露丝。就是这样。好吧，各位，希望你们喜欢听这个访谈，你知道，既然我们俩都忙于各自的其他项目，我们就依靠了一些朋友和其他播客来采访我们，然后我们得以与大家分享。所以我们真的很希望你们喜欢。祝大家有个美好的一周。终于，我可以对大家说这句话了，你好，芝士蛋糕妈妈。你好，爸爸。哦，我们太高兴了。你太漂亮了。你容光焕发。你光彩照人。你就是全场的焦点。你就是偶像。我很高兴能和你一起回到录音室。我想念你和
cheesecakes. I have noticed that we've started saying cheesies and I might like it even more than cheesecake. I love the cheeses. I love the cheesies. I'm seeing the cheesies on the road. They are always asking me about you. We send you videos. They love you. How are you? I'm great. I've missed you. I'm so glad to be back. I thought our graham cracker crust killed it. Steve is the greatest. I know. I know. He worked so hard. He was so excited to be here. He really wanted to like do you justice? Listen, we are a team and I love teamwork. My parents raised me. My mom was my softball coach. My dad, my brother's baseball coach. And more than anything, they stressed the power and importance of teamwork. So I'm so proud to be part of this team. I love you so much.
芝士蛋糕了。我注意到我们开始叫它们“芝芝”了，我可能比喜欢芝士蛋糕更喜欢这个称呼。我爱芝芝。我爱芝芝。我在路上见到了芝芝们。他们总是向我打听你。我们给你发视频。他们太爱你啦。你好吗？我很好。我想念你。很高兴能回来。我觉得我们的全麦饼干底棒极了。史蒂夫是最棒的。我知道。我知道。他工作太努力了。他很高兴能来到这里。他真的很想不辜负大家的期望。听着，我们是一个团队，我热爱团队合作。我的父母抚养我长大。我妈妈是我的垒球教练。我爸爸是我哥哥的棒球教练。比起其他任何事情，他们都强调团队合作的力量和重要性。所以我为能成为这个团队的一员感到无比骄傲。我太爱你们了。
But we are getting to this episode, this interview with the office ladies, Angela and Jenna, from the office ladies, from the office. I'm obsessed. I cannot wait to talk to them. I can't wait either. Before we get there, I just want to ask you, what was it like to go viral like a hundred times? It was so incredible. And you know the best part is it's not something that was manipulated from our show. No. Where in the number hit me, I have this line, this is, that was root. That was pretty effing rude.
但我们要进入这一集，也就是对《办公室女士》的安吉拉和珍娜的采访，她们来自《办公室女士》，来自《办公室》。我着迷了。我迫不及待地想和她们聊聊。我也迫不及待。在我们开始之前，我只想问你，像病毒一样火了一百次是什么感觉？太不可思议了。而且你知道最棒的部分是，这不是我们节目刻意操纵出来的。没有。当我看到那个数字时，我有句台词，就是那个，这太粗鲁了。这真特么粗鲁。
And, of course, I say the real word. Yeah. And it just took off. So it happened while I was sleeping, so to speak. And I woke up, and here's this viral moment. I mean, unreal. Like, I saw you, like, Madonna did it. Yeah.
当然，我说的是原话。是的。然后它就火了。所以它发生在我睡觉的时候，可以说是这样。我醒来时，就有了这个病毒式的热门时刻。我的意思是，太不真实了。就像我看到你一样，麦当娜也用了。是的。
I mean, that is crazy. It was everywhere. It was all over the internet. We're going to get way more into this in the future. but like the Tony's, you were nominated. It was glorious. How was it for you? It was incredible.
我的意思是，这太疯狂了。到处都是。全网都是。我们以后会深入探讨这个话题，但是比如托尼奖，你被提名了。这太荣耀了。对你来说感觉如何？太不可思议了。
You know, to be nominated with Megan, my co-star was perfection. Yes. And then to be among those women, one of whom is Audra McDonald. And I've known her since she was Audra Ann McDonald. Is that right? Yeah, I met her singing at St. Clair's Hospital, which is no longer there, with Seth Rudetsky. And that day I met Norm Lewis. Oh, my God.
你知道，能和我的联合主演梅根一起被提名真是太完美了。是的。然后能和那些女性并列，其中一位是奥德拉·麦克唐纳。我从她叫奥德拉·安·麦克唐纳时就认识她了。是吗？是的，我是在圣克莱尔医院（现在已经不存在了）和塞思·鲁德茨基一起唱歌时认识她的。那天我遇到了诺姆·刘易斯。哦，天哪。
And Audra. And her name at that time was Audra Ann. and she was in between her first audition for Carousel and her callback. No way. Which ended up being her first Tony Award and changed everything for her. Yeah, yeah. You know, and we're the same age, you know, so it's just, it was so special. We're like, we're still here, you know?
还有奥德拉。她当时的名字叫奥德拉·安，她当时正处于《carousel》的第一次试镜和复试之间。不会吧。结果那成了她的第一个托尼奖，并改变了一切。是的，是的。你知道，我们年龄一样，所以，这真的很特别。我们就像是，我们还在呢，你知道吗？
And we just kind of sent each other supportive messages, and that was really great. That's what I love, because it, tell me if I'm wrong, but it seems like it doesn't feel competitive between the nominees, that you are all really supporting each other. It's inherently competitive because that's technically what it is. But if you don't treat it, it that way and just have fun, then it really is the right way to do it. And that's, I believe, the way we try to approach it all. Well, Cheezies, listen, if you will allow it, we're going to do a
我们只是互相发送了支持的信息，这真的很棒。这就是我所热爱的，因为，如果我错了请纠正我，提名者之间似乎并没有竞争的感觉，你们所有人都在真正地支持彼此。从本质上讲它是有竞争性的，因为这在技术上就是这么回事。但如果你不那样对待它，只是去享受乐趣，那这才是真正正确的做法。我相信，这就是我们所有人试图采取的方式。好吧，芝芝们，听着，如果你们允许的话，我们将花
whole talk about your last couple of months because you've been away. You've been so busy. Like, everything has gotten crazy for you. Yeah. But right now, we need to get to this interview with Angela and Jenna from the office, from the Office Ladies podcast. I got to tell you, we work with a company called Odyssey. They are the ones who sell our ads for us. They support us. They've been marketing us. They have been so, so supportive of this podcast. And from the beginning, we were like, it'd be such a dream. Because Angela and Jenna worked with them as well. And we were like, it'd be such a dream to get them.
整段节目来聊聊你们过去的几个月，因为你们一直在外地。你们太忙了。感觉你们的一切都变得疯狂了。是的。但现在，我们需要开始对来自《办公室女士》播客的安吉拉和珍娜的采访。我必须告诉你们，我们与一家名为Odyssey的公司合作。他们是为我们出售广告的人。他们支持我们。他们一直在为我们进行市场推广。他们对这个播客给予了极大的支持。从一开始我们就觉得，这将是一个梦想。因为安吉拉和珍娜也与他们合作。我们当时就想，如果能请到她们，那将是一个梦想。
We're like, we're going to really try to make this happen. And as far back as Christmas, both Angela and Jenna wanted to do this interview. They just are so busy and had so much going on. It finally made sense for them to do it now. We're going to have a bunch of social media. So go to our social media so you can see some of the videos of this conversation that we're about to have. I'm so delighted. I can't wait to talk with you with them.
我们当时想，我们要真正努力让这件事发生。早在圣诞节时，安吉拉和珍娜就想做这个采访。她们只是太忙了，有太多事情要做。现在对她们来说终于合适了。我们将发布很多社交媒体内容。所以请关注我们的社交媒体，这样你们就可以看到我们即将进行的这次对话的一些视频。我太高兴了。我等不及要和她们对话了。
Yeah, me too. And, you know, one of the things we're going to talk about is the Barbara Thorndyke episode of the Golden Girls for a million reasons. But, like, technically, I have so many questions for them about being a guest star, what it takes to be a good guest star, working with guest stars. They're the experts. I've got a lot of questions about this, just about, you know, their podcast, superstars, how did that happen? It's going to be a great conversation. So, uh, shall we dive in? Let's dive in.
是的，我也是。而且，你知道，我们要谈论的事情之一就是《黄金女郎》的芭芭拉·索恩代克那一集，原因有无数个。但是，从技术上讲，关于如何成为一名客串明星、成为一名优秀的客串明星需要什么、以及与客串明星合作，我有很多问题想问她们。她们是专家。我有很多关于这方面的问题，关于她们的播客、超级巨星，这是怎么做到的？这将是一次很棒的对话。所以，呃，我们要开始吗？我们开始吧。
So Jenna Fisher and. Angela Kinsey, I cannot tell you what an honor this is. To be on a Zoom, not just with the two of you, but with Jennifer Smart as well. Like, I don't know what I did in this life to get to be on the Zoom with the three of you. We are overwhelmed. We're honored. Our listeners have been begging for this crossover forever. So welcome to the Golden Girls Deep Dive podcast.
所以珍娜·费舍尔和。安吉拉·金斯利，我无法表达这是多么大的荣幸。能够在一个Zoom会议里，不仅和你们两位在一起，还和詹妮弗·萨马德在一起。就像，我不知道我这辈子做了什么，才能和你们三个人一起开Zoom。我们受宠若惊。我们感到很荣幸。我们的听众一直在苦苦哀求这次跨界合作。所以欢迎来到《黄金女郎深度解析》播客。
Welcome. Thank you so much for having us. Yeah, we're so tickled. I have to say, I love that it's a glasses convention. We're all wearing my glasses. Oh, yeah. Cheesecakes. Yes, we love it, don't we?
欢迎。非常感谢邀请我们。是的，我们太高兴了。我必须说，我喜欢这是一个眼镜大会。我们都戴着我的眼镜。哦，是的。芝士蛋糕迷们。是的，我们很喜欢，对吧？
We're all looks so cute. It is. And I want to be. And I want to be able to see you. Yeah, that part. That part right there. You two are such big stars. I was waiting for like the presidential.
我们看起来都好可爱。确实是的。而且我也想。而且我也想能见到你。没错，就是那个部分。就是那里的那个部分。你们两个真是超级巨星。我还在等着那种总统级别的欢迎。
Like, please hold for Angela Kinsey and Jenna Fisher. And then like you pop in very officially. But you're so down to earth. You're just like the rest of us. Oh my gosh. Yeah. Angela and I are, we're besties. And we do the podcast together.
比如，请接听安吉拉·金斯利（Angela Kinsey）和珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）的电话。然后你就非常官方地出场了。但你们又是那么平易近人。你们就像我们其他人一样。哦天哪。没错。安吉拉和我，我们是死党。我们一起做播客。
And we do all the other things together too, like organize each other's closets. And we don't have assistance or anything. It's just us, just us, gals. Just us gals. Jen refuses to organize my closet. I've been begging and begging and begging. Oh, it's so fun to do it together. But I don't have months.
我们还一起做其他所有事情，比如帮对方整理衣橱。我们没有助理什么的。只有我们，只有我们这群好姐妹。只有我们这群好姐妹。珍拒绝帮我整理衣橱。我一直在苦苦哀求。哦，一起做这件事太有趣了。但我没有几个月的时间。
I don't have months is the problem. That's how long it would take. Oh, sorry, Patrick. I know. So sorry. Listen, here's the thing. We all know as huge fans, you are both sitcom icons. I mean, icons.
我没有几个月的时间，这就是问题所在。这就是需要花费的时间。哦，对不起，帕特里克（Patrick）。我知道。真的很抱歉。听着，情况是这样的。作为忠实粉丝，我们都知道你们两个都是情景喜剧的传奇人物。我的意思是，绝对是传奇。
The office is an iconic sitcom. It's lasted the test of time, as has the goal. Golden Girls. It's also an iconic sitcom. What is your relationship to the Golden Girls? And what do you think it is about shows like yours and the Golden Girls that make them so timeless, if you had to guess? Oh, well, gosh, you know, to be able to be a part of a show that people keep connecting to over the years, over and over multiple generations. You can't even believe that you won that lottery ticket, you know? And we all grew up with shows like that. We all grew up with shows that we watched with our parents when we didn't even and hang out with them otherwise, right, in those teen years. And so that's really meaningful. And I think the Golden Girls and the office and shows like them that stand the test of time have relationships that people connect with, right? And Jen and I, we've sort of seen this as we go out in the world. Like, whether you're at a hospital or you're at a homeroom classroom, there's always a Dwight, right? And it doesn't matter where you work. There's probably a persnickety, Angela.
《办公室》是一部传奇情景喜剧。它经受住了时间的考验，《黄金女郎》也是如此。《黄金女郎》也是一部传奇情景喜剧。你们和《黄金女郎》有什么渊源？如果要你猜的话，你认为像你们这样的节目和《黄金女郎》为什么能如此经久不衰？哦，天哪，你知道的，能够参与到一个让人们多年来、一次又一次、跨越好几代人不断产生共鸣的节目中，你简直不敢相信自己中了大奖，你知道吗？我们都是看着这样的节目长大的。我们都是看着那些在青少年时期甚至不用跟父母一起玩、但会和父母一起看的节目长大的，对吧？所以这真的很有意义。而且我认为《黄金女郎》和《办公室》以及那些经受住时间考验的节目，都有能引起人们共鸣的人际关系，对吧？珍和我，我们在走进现实世界时也看到了这一点。比如，无论你是在医院还是在教室里，总会有一个德怀特（Dwight），对吧？不管你在哪里工作，可能都有一个挑剔的安吉拉。
Yeah. And then you've got to have that relationship you're rooting for. And I think for the Golden Girls, it's that sisterhood, right? And for the office, it was Jim and Pam. I like to think some people were rooting for Dwight and Angela. I 100% was. I was like, somebody's got to set him right. She's the only one who can do it.
是的。然后你还得有那种让你为之加油打气的关系。我想对于《黄金女郎》来说，那是姐妹情谊，对吧？而对于《办公室》来说，那是吉姆（Jim）和帕姆（Pam）。我倾向于认为有些人一直在为德怀特和安吉拉加油。我百分之百是。我当时想，总得有人来管管他。她是唯一能做到这一点的人。
That's right. That's right. Her and her clipboard. I married and Angela, by the way. So I totally 100%. I married like the child of Angela and Pam. Steve is the marriage of those two characters. So I very much relate to that dynamic.
没错。没错。她和她的剪贴板。顺便说一句，我娶了一个“安吉拉”。所以我完全百分之百。我娶的就像是安吉拉和帕姆的结合体。史蒂夫（Steve）就是这两个角色的结合体。所以我对那种动态关系非常有共鸣。
Well, I just think those shows have such huge themes about life and love and loss and trying to find your way. And whether they're set in a sort of community in Florida or in a small office, that's what people connect to. You know, it's not that we work at a paper company. That's not it. It's that journey of life that happens. Yeah, I agree with all of that. So I watched the Golden Girls when it was on. Oh, okay, good.
嗯，我只是觉得这些节目有着关于生活、爱情、失落以及寻找自我方向的宏大主题。无论它们的背景是佛罗里达的一个社区还是一个小办公室，这都是人们产生共鸣的地方。你知道的，并不是因为我们在纸业公司工作。根本不是因为这个。而是生活的那段旅程发生了。是的，我同意所有这些。所以《黄金女郎》热播的时候我看过。哦，太好了，很好。
Everybody else, appointment viewing. Yes. Appointment television, yeah. Yeah, one of my favorite shows. And I hadn't watched it in forever until we said we were going to do this collaboration. But then something that I remembered in watching it was like how Golden Girls wasn't afraid to get dramatic. Like all these storylines started flooding in for me.
其他人都是准时收看。是的。按时看电视，对吧。是的，我最喜欢的节目之一。在我们要进行这次合作之前，我已经很久没有看过了。但后来在观看时，我记起的一件事是，《黄金女郎》是多么勇于展现戏剧性。就像所有这些故事情节开始向我涌来一样。
And I was like, I think that might be part of it, too, is that, you know, it rings all the comedy bells. But then every once in a while, it kind of like, ooh, it tugs at your heartstrings. Mm-hmm. Or makes you think about something. Like, oh, yeah. Yeah. Do you think in that vein that the office comes from that sort of lineage? Because the office certainly has.
我当时想，我想这可能也是原因的一部分，你知道的，它完美触动了所有喜剧的笑点。但随后每隔一段时间，它就会，哦，它会触动你的心弦。嗯哼。或者让你思考一些事情。比如，哦，是的。是的。你认为从这个角度来看，《办公室》也源于那种血统吗？因为《办公室》确实有。
I was thinking, too, about, like, there are moments when you see Angela cry. And those are some of the most emotional moments of the office for me. Like, Pam is such a sweet soul. But, you know, and my God, the Pam's arc towards the end. Like, it's very tear jerky. But I do think it surprises people when they go back and look at the Golden Girls that there are moments you could cry. There are moments that are really dry.
我也在想，比如，有些时刻你会看到安吉拉哭泣。对我来说，那些是《办公室》中最具情感张力的时刻。比如，帕姆是一个如此甜美善良的灵魂。但是，天哪，帕姆后期的角色弧光。真的非常催人泪下。但我确实认为，当人们回过头来看《黄金女郎》时，会惊讶于其中有些时刻确实能让你哭泣。有些时刻真的很感人。
And, you know, do you think that the office comes from that sort of tradition in sitcom? Yeah, I think a little bit. I mean, I know that that was kind of one of the gifts. of the way we shot the show was that we could pull the camera back and we could observe these more private, intimate moments of characters, which is something you don't get to do a lot in comedy. And so, yeah, I mean, 100%. Yeah, and I think Golden Girls is just classic television comedy writing.
而且，你知道，你认为《办公室》源自情景喜剧的这种传统吗？是的，我觉得有一点。我的意思是，我知道那是我们拍摄节目方式的优势之一，那就是我们可以拉远镜头，观察角色更私密、更亲密的时刻，这是你在喜剧中很难做到的。所以，是的，百分之百。是的，而且我认为《黄金女郎》就是经典的电视喜剧写作。
You know, you have each character is their own little season and spice, and they bring something unique. They have a unique point of view. And you can count on that point of view. and you get excited for it. You know Sophia, right? You know what she's going to deliver. Yeah. And I think the office had that too. Your characters, they grow a little bit, but they don't grow so much that they're still not who you want them to be. And that's just great, great comedy writing. Also great performing, great acting, because you are such beautiful actors in your show. And so, too,
你知道，每个角色都有他们自己独特的风味和特色，他们带来了一些独特的东西。他们有独特的观点。你可以依赖那个观点，你会为之兴奋。你知道索菲亚（Sophia），对吧？你知道她会带来什么。是的。我认为《办公室》也有这一点。你们的角色有所成长，但他们的成长并没有让他们失去原本的特质，依然是你想看到的那个他们。这真的是非常非常棒的喜剧剧本。同时也是非常棒的表演，非常棒的演技，因为你们在剧中的演员表现得太出色了。
are the actors in the Golden Girls. And give me any actor who's capable of, comedy, and I guarantee you they can be a sad clown when they need to be. But it's not always true in reverse. So my hat's off to both of you. Thank you. Just very, very talented. You're welcome. We have a Golden Girls Office crossover. We do. Yes. What is it? And I was so tickled when we heard it in this episode. Tell me. What are you talking about? I'm talking about Kent Zabornack. Me too. Because the inscription in the book that Barbara gives Dorothy, It says to Dorothy Zabornack, and I said, oh my gosh, I just heard his name in the episode. That's right.
《黄金女郎》中的演员也是如此。给我任何一个有喜剧才华的演员，我敢保证他们在需要的时候也能成为一个悲伤的小丑。但反过来却不一定总是成立。所以我要向你们两人致敬。谢谢。真的非常非常有才华。不客气。《黄金女郎》和《办公室》来了一场跨界联动。我们确实有。是的。是什么？当我们在这集里听到的时候，我高兴坏了。告诉我。你在说什么？我说的是肯特·扎博纳克（Kent Zbornak）。我也是。因为芭芭拉（Barbara）送给多萝西（Dorothy）的书上的题词，上面写着送给多萝西·扎博纳克，我说，哦天哪，我刚在这集里听到他的名字。没错。
Yes. That's right. Our co-exec producer, Kent Zabornak, was an assistant to Susan Harris, and she liked his last name so much that when she had to name Dorothy, she gave Dorothy the last name Sabornaq. And then that's the origin story. Yes. But I didn't realize that he also worked on the office. That's incredible. He was a producer for those first seasons that really.
是的。没错。我们的联合执行制片人肯特·扎博纳克曾是苏珊·哈里斯（Susan Harris）的助理，她太喜欢他的姓氏了，所以在给多萝西命名时，她给了多萝西“扎博纳克”这个姓氏。这就是幕后故事。是的。但我没有意识到他也参与过《办公室》的工作。这太不可思议了。他是前几季的制片人，真的。
developed the whole show and yeah he's wonderful and and that is just it just tickled us when we found that out and he did end up he also worked on golden girls and he told us because we asked him we were like zabornak that's a very specific name and he said that when he did eventually meet b arthur and she found out that her character was you know his namesake he said she was so kind and she almost became like a second mother to him. He just loved her. Oh my God. So sweet. That is incredible. I wanted to ask the two of you as actors, the thing about the Golden Girls, it's never been off the air, right? Like, from the day it was on for four decades now, it's never been off the air. It's one of those comfort shows. And when we were asking our listeners what they wanted to know about from you all, one of the questions that you got
打造了整部剧，是的，他很棒。当我们发现这件事时，我们真的兴奋坏了。而且他最后确实也参与了《黄金女郎》的工作，他告诉我们——因为我们问过他，我们当时说：“扎博纳克，这是一个非常独特的姓氏”——他说当他最终见到贝·亚瑟（Bea Arthur）并且她发现自己的角色是用他的名字命名时，他说她非常善良，几乎就像他的第二个母亲一样。他非常喜欢她。哦天哪。太甜了。这太不可思议了。我想问你们两个作为演员，关于《黄金女郎》的一点是，它从未停播过，对吧？就像从它开播的那天算起，历经四十年，它从未停播过。它是那种让人感觉舒适的节目之一。当我们问听众他们想从你们那里了解什么时，你们收到的问题之一是
in a bunch of different ways is sort of what does it like for you as actors to know? Like, I mean, in my house, we've watched the office straight through no fewer than eight, nine times. And I mean, that is a commitment, but now you can get through it in three months or whatever, you know? And what does it feel like for you all to know that like this is going to outlive you? No question. Like it'll be around long after we leave this plane. You know, and not very, very, very few shows, I think have that kind of history eventually. How does it feel to be a part of that? I mean, it's very humbling. And, Also, it's very moving to me. I mean, I know that we, our show, the office, it does everything from just beyond the background while people make dinner to helping people while they're going through a medical crisis. You know, I can't tell you how many people tell us, oh, this is what we watch to get through chemotherapy or this helped me when I was grieving, the loss of someone. And so to be that kind of comfort and
从各种不同的角度来看，作为演员，得知这一切是什么感觉？我的意思是，在我家里，我们已经把《办公室》从头到尾看了不下八、九遍。我的意思是，这是一种承诺，但现在你可以在三个月左右的时间里看完它，你知道的？当你们知道这将会比你们活得还久时，是什么感觉？毫无疑问。就像在我们离开这个世界很久之后，它依然会存在。你知道，我认为很少有节目能拥有这种历史。成为其中一部分是什么感觉？我的意思是，这非常让人谦卑。
constant. It takes something that was just the most fun thing in the world to do, a comedy television show, into feeling so meaningful and I'm so happy, you know? Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I think we just sit in a lot of gratitude. And it was so much fun to do. And, you know, I had this writing professor that said, what's a pleasure to write is a pleasure to read. And I always thought about that when we were on the set because we were having so much fun. And I just was like, surely, I hope people watch this and have that same joy that we have doing it. We spent most our days trying not to ruin each other's scenes because we were laughing so hard. And that was just what a gift. And to know that it has such meaning that will just go on and on is very surreal. It's special.
而且，这也让我非常感动。我的意思是，我知道我们的节目，《办公室》所做的事情从人们做饭时的背景音乐到帮助人们度过医疗危机。你知道，我无法告诉你有多少人对我们说，哦，这就是我们用来熬过化疗的节目，或者这在我哀悼某人的离去时给予了我帮助。所以能够成为那种安慰和陪伴
It's humbling, like Jenna said. And then it's also, it's also kind of strange. sometimes because I forget, you know, you just go about your life, you're at the grocery store or whatever, you're dropping your kid off at soccer practice. And that part of your life is on the back burner in your mind and someone will see you and yell, you know, like, green is horrish. And you're like, what? What? And then you're like, oh, yes, right, of course. That's right. With Amex Platinum, access to exclusive Amex pre-sale tickets, score you a spot trackside. So being a fan for life turns into the trip of a lifetime. That's the powerful backing of Amex. Pre-sale tickets for future events subject to availability and
让这件世界上最有趣的事情——一部喜剧电视节目——变得如此有意义，我太高兴了，你知道吗？是的。是的。我的意思是，我觉得我们内心充满了感激。而且拍摄过程真的非常有趣。你知道，我有一位写作教授曾说过，写起来是一种乐趣，读起来也是一种乐趣。我在片场时总是会想起这句话，因为我们玩得太开心了。我当时就想，当然了，我希望人们在看这部剧时能拥有我们拍摄时一样的快乐。我们大部分的时间都在努力不毁掉彼此的戏份，因为我们笑得太厉害了。这真的是一份厚礼。而且知道它具有将不断延续下去的意义，这非常超现实。这很特别。
vary by race. Terms and conditions apply. Learn more at Amex.com slash Y-Amex. Hit pause on whatever you're listening to and hit play on your next adventure. This fall get double points on every qualified stay. Life's the trip. Make the most of it at Best Western. Visit bestwestern.com for complete terms and conditions. are legitimate podcast stars now. I'm going to combine this a little bit, but like, what does that feel like? You said earlier, there's been a learning curve, which is so humble of you to even say. But of course, there is anything in life. But, you know, what inspired you to make the podcast in the first place? And was it important to you that it wasn't just a recap podcast? So,
正如珍娜所说，这让人感到谦卑。而且有时候也挺奇怪的，因为我会忘记，你知道的，你只是在过着自己的生活，你在杂货店或者做别的什么，你在送孩子去踢足球。生活的那一部分在你的脑海中被搁置了，然后有人会看到你并大喊，你知道的，比如，“绿色很可怕（green is horrish）”。你会想，什么？什么？然后你会想，哦，对了，当然。没错。通过美国运通白金卡，您可以享受独家美国运通预售门票，在赛道旁为您赢得一席之地。因此，成为终身粉丝就会变成一生难忘的旅行。这就是美国运通强大的后盾。未来活动的预售门票视供应情况而定，并且
you know, all of those as the legitimate podcast stars you are. Well, I think one of the biggest things was ever since the office ended, Angela and I wanted to work together again. Nice. There is nothing like getting to go to work every day with your very best friend, the person you trust the most. Yeah. And so we were always looking for that opportunity. And we didn't know what that was. We were like, is it a TV show? We would joke that we wanted to take over the fourth hour of the today show and just drink
因比赛而异。适用条款和条件。了解更多信息请访问 Amex.com 顺斜线 Y-Amex。暂停您正在收听的任何内容，点击播放您的下一场冒险。今年秋天，每次符合条件的入住均可获得双倍积分。生活就是一场旅行。在贝斯特韦斯特酒店（Best Western）尽情享受吧。访问 bestwestern.com 了解完整的条款和条件。你们现在是实至名归的播客明星了。我要把这些稍微结合一下，比如，那是什么感觉？你刚才说，有一个学习曲线，你这么说真的很谦逊。但当然，生活中的任何事情都是如此。但是，你知道是什么启发了你们一开始做播客？对你们来说，它不仅仅是一个回顾类播客，这很重要吗？所以，
wine and chat in the mornings with people about events. We were like, we just need to be best friends working together. But then the other thing that was happening after the office was we were like full-time, now we were in the season of our lives with our young children. And going off to a set for like 12, 14 hours a day was really hard on our mom hearts. And we would talk about that too. We would say, how can we have a really fun creative job that we do together that also allows us to be at all of those milestones as a parent, at all of the soccer games and the volleyball games and the school performances and the parent teacher conferences? Like, is there, what's that job? Can we find
你知道，作为你们这些实至名归的播客明星。嗯，我想最大的事情之一就是，自从《办公室》结束以来，安吉拉和我就一直想再次合作。太棒了。没有什么比每天和你的最好朋友、你最信任的人一起去上班更好的了。是的。所以我们一直在寻找那样的机会。我们当时不知道那是什么。我们想，是一部电视剧吗？我们曾开玩笑说，我们想接管《今日秀》的第四小时，早上只喝
it. And that was how we kind of honed in on podcasting. Yeah. Now, was this your idea? And if you don't mind me saying, we were chatting a little bit about this before we started. I got into podcasting about nine years ago because I fell in love with the art of podcasting. And then, of course, the zone got flooded. And it's not very often that a game changer podcast presents itself. And your podcast came out and was so instantly beloved and seemed to be exactly what the world needed. at the exact moment. So I guess my question is, like, was it your two's idea to do the podcast?
酒，和大家一起聊聊各种活动。我们当时想，我们只需要成为一起工作的最好朋友。但后来《办公室》结束后发生的另一件事是，我们成了全职妈妈，现在我们迎来了生活中带着幼小孩子的阶段。每天去片场12到14个小时，对我们母亲的心来说真的很艰难。我们也会谈论这件事。我们会说，我们怎样才能拥有一份真正有趣且具有创造力的工作，既能一起做，又能让我们不错过作为父母的所有重要里程碑，不错过所有的足球赛、排球赛、学校演出和家长会？比如，有没有这样一份工作，我们能找到
Did people approach you about the podcast? And did you know that you wanted to, like, really give the behind-the-scenes experience more than just recapping the episodes? I mean, the way it started, we had no idea that it was going to be a rewatch podcast. Really, we had a ton of memorabilia, photos, scripts, you name it.
它吗。这就是我们如何逐渐聚焦于播客的原因。是的。那么，这主意是你们出的吗？如果您不介意我这么说，在我们开始之前，我们曾稍微聊过这个。我大约九年前开始涉足播客，因为我爱上了播客这门艺术。然后，当然，市场上就泛滥了。一个改变游戏规则的播客出现并不常见。而你们的播客一问世就立刻大受欢迎，并且似乎正是这个世界在那个精确时刻所需要的。所以我想我的问题是，比如，做播客是你们两个人的主意吗？
Jenna and I sort of were the historians of the show. We saved everything. We took a ton of pictures. And we started this project that we had wanted to do for years to clean out our sheds and closets. I told you we cleaned things together. This really happened. And the thing is, neither of us were doing it until we're like, okay, we're both going to do it. And in that process, I think I found out that I clearly have some weird obsession with baskets. I had like 32 baskets. Jenna had so many lamps. I'm like, why are you keeping all these lamps? I was convinced I was going to rewind. them. I know. I know. But anyway, we found boxes and boxes of our office memorabilia. And we were like, we want to preserve this for our kids. We weren't really sure how. And we decided to each take a Halloween, our bin of Halloween pictures and stories and rewatch a Halloween episode and sort of just like make notes, right? Like an oral history sort of like we just wanted to get it down. Like what would you call that? Like journaling out loud. journaling out loud. And we weren't, you know, no real idea what we were going to do with that session. We just wanted to do something with it. We didn't know if it would eventually lead to a book or a podcast or just us getting this history down for our kids. So Jenna came over and I got lunch. And we sat in, we have a garage that we kind of made into a bonus room. And we sat on my IKEA couch out there and put my iPhone between the two of us on the couch and hit record.
有人就播客的事联系过你们吗？你们是否知道自己想真正提供幕后体验，而不仅仅是回顾剧集？我的意思是，刚开始的时候，我们根本不知道这会是一个重温剧集的播客。真的，我们有大量的纪念品、照片、剧本，应有尽有。
Yes. And Jenna shared hers, which was a very structured, outlined, thoughtful. I like wrote like a three-page document. Yes. And I, you see these note cards behind me? I had a stack of these note cards with my notes and ideas and pictures. And the two of us had such a different approach to a shared memory. We both had the same memory. And we came at it from such two different perspectives. And we just laughed and talked. And it was really fun. And I hit Stop Rec, court at the end. And my husband is a really good editor. And he listened to it. I sent it to Jenna and her husband and my husband. And our husbands listened to it. And Josh said to me, Ange, this is a podcast. And Jenna's husband said the same thing. He was like, you guys have something here. Wow. Wow. So we took it out. Yeah. Josh edited it to a little sizzle, you know, kind of thing. And we took it out ourselves. Wow. That's incredible. I love that story. And it just goes to show you everyone, like, just create. Just do the thing. You never know what can become of it. I'm inspired, Patrick. I do want to ask the first listener question because they brought up memorabilia. Oh, yeah. You know what I mean? Yeah. We got a question from a listener named Kathleen. So for both of you, for followers of office ladies and office BFFs, we all know what props set decor they kept from the office. I want to know, Kathleen wants to know, what Golden Girls prop or decor they would.
珍娜和我有点像是该剧的历史学家。我们保存了一切。我们拍了大量的照片。我们开始了这个我们多年来一直想做的项目，那就是清理我们的储藏室和衣橱。我告诉过你们我们一起清理东西。这真的发生了。问题是，我们俩谁也没有真的去做，直到我们想，好吧，我们俩都要一起做。在这个过程中，我发现我显然对篮子有着某种奇怪的执念。我当时大概有32个篮子。珍娜有那么多的台灯。我说，你为什么留着所有这些台灯？我当时确信我要重新给它们缠线。我知道。我知道。不管怎样，我们找到了成箱成箱的《办公室》纪念品。我们当时想，我们想为我们的孩子保存这些。我们其实并不确定怎么做。我们决定各自拿出一个万圣节的收纳箱，里面装满了万圣节的照片和故事，然后重温一万圣节那一集，并做点笔记，对吧？就像口述历史一样，就像我们只是想把它记录下来。你会怎么称呼那个？就像大声写日记。大声写日记。而且我们当时，你知道，对于那一期节目到底要做什么并没有真正的想法。我们只是想用它做点什么。我们不知道这最终会引出一本书、一个播客，还是仅仅为我们的孩子们记录下这段历史。所以珍娜过来了，我准备了午餐。我们坐在车库里，我们把车库改造成了一个多功能房。我们坐在那里的宜家沙发上，把我的iPhone放在沙发上我们俩中间，然后按下了录音键。
love to have. Oh, well, I mean, okay. Jen is raising her. No, you go first. I have something from this episode that I want very badly. What? Okay, yes. So we're going to talk about the episode Dorothy's new friend in a minute. So that's the episode you're talking about. Okay. But I would take, just in general, I would take anything in their kitchen. Oh, yes. The tablecloth, like any of the kitchen decor is amazing. from this episode specifically, though, I've become somewhat obsessed with Blanche's yellow pants suit.
好想要。哦，好吧，我是说，好吧。珍正在抚养她。不，你先说。这一集里有件东西我非常想要。什么？好吧，是的。所以我们一会儿要聊聊《桃乐丝的新朋友》那一集。所以这就是你们在聊的那一集。好吧。不过总的来说，我想要他们厨房里的任何东西。哦，对。桌布，还有任何厨房的装饰都太棒了。不过特别是从这一集开始，我对布兰奇的黄色裤装有点着迷了。
And if I could buy it and wear it, I would 100% do it. All right. I feel like you could rock so many of Blanche's out. Like the red number with the thing at the top, oh my God, you'd be perfect in that. It's, they all look comfy.
如果我能买到并穿上它，我100%会这么做。好吧。我觉得你可以完美驾驭布兰奇的很多造型。就像那件上面有装饰的红色裙装，天哪，你穿一定绝配。它们的衣服看起来都很舒服。
They do. They look like they breathe and move with you. Yeah. You know? Yeah. I'm obsessed with all of the wicker and the coral. So like that furniture set in the living room, the couch and the chair,
确实。它们看起来透气又贴身。是啊。你知道吗？对。我迷恋所有的柳条和珊瑚色的东西。比如客厅里的那一套家具，沙发和椅子，
I mean, I want it. I want that wicker chair. Yeah. I truly do. And there's 72 coral napkins. They have so many coral napkins. You know what I would take? If I can take anything. And I would frame, we have big walls in my apartment and I would take the front door with that exclamation mark. You know, I don't know if you've seen it, but there's like the there's an exclamation mark sort of chiseled into the front door. And I would put it on the wall behind like plexiglass or something. Oh, yeah. Oh, I love that.
我是说，我想要。我想要那张藤椅。真的。我是说真的。还有72张珊瑚色的餐巾。他们有那么多的珊瑚色餐巾。你知道我会拿什么吗？如果我可以拿任何东西的话。我要把前门那个带有感叹号的门框裱起来，我们公寓有很大的墙。你知道的，我不知道你有没有见过，前门上好像雕刻了一个感叹号。我会把它挂在墙上，外面罩上有机玻璃什么的。哦，是的。哦，我太喜欢了。
Or you could make a dining table out of it. Oh, that's a good idea. I would take the copper lobster mold on the wall that looks like a penis. Yes. Well, let's talk about, so, you know, we asked you, and you so kindly did watch the episode, Dorothy's new friend, which is, you know, it's made iconic by the actress Bonnie Bartlett. It's the episode where Barbara Thorndyke is Dorothy's new friend and she's kind of a jerk and, you know, the other women see it, but Dorothy doesn't really see it.
或者你可以用它做一个餐桌。哦，这是个好主意。我要拿走墙上那个看起来像个阴茎的铜龙虾模具。没错。好吧，我们来聊聊，你知道的，我们问过你，你也非常友善地看了《桃乐丝的新朋友》那一集，你知道的，这一集因为女演员邦尼·巴特利特而成为了经典。这就是芭芭拉·桑迪克成为桃乐丝的新朋友的那一集，她有点像个混蛋，你知道的，其他女人都看出来了，但桃乐丝却没有真正看出来。
So my question is, do you think this episode is iconic and if so, why? I mean, I do because it's about friendship and it's that new person that enters in sort of the old guard, the group, you know, and that is a very common theme. It's super relatable. We've all lived it. We have. We've all had a good friend group and then had a new person join, and you're like, well, what, what's, what's happening here? Right.
所以我的问题是，你觉得这一集算经典吗？如果是，为什么？我是说，我觉得是，因为它讲的是友谊，是那种融入老一辈、融入团体的新人，你知道的，这是一个非常普遍的主题。这超级有共鸣。我们都经历过。确实经历过。我们都曾有过一个很好的朋友圈，然后有新人加入，你就会想，呃，什么，什么情况这是？对吧。
So, and then also, it has that very sweet ending where, you know, Dorothy is going to stand up for her friends and, and her mom and her mom's friend, you know. So I loved the ending. I always, whenever I hear the word metaphor, it always takes me right back to this, you know, I know what a is dear and then also like the titles of the books like there was a the episode that we're actually doing our regular episode on today when we're done with this there's a shot of the hospital from the outside of this is like Biscayne Bay hospital and I'm always saying like so dark the waves on Biscayne Bay but Jenna what do you think? I'm sorry Patrick yeah what I'm sorry to the group sorry what is a metaphor don't don't worry about it I'm not worried about it okay I also just loved and I know we're jumping around here but I loved how snooty Barbara was and her brooch, you know, that she found in Morocco, and now she's never had writers walk again. I'm like, and then I love the snark. Was it, was it Rose who said our blanche that you can't wear it with plaid? I just loved that. And then I love when someone is snooty and purposely gets a name wrong. Like the fact that she kept calling her match was so
所以，然后还有，它有一个非常温馨的结局，你知道的，桃乐丝要为她的朋友们、她的妈妈以及她妈妈的朋友挺身而出，你知道的。所以我爱这个结局。我总是，每当我听到“隐喻”这个词，它总是直接把我带回这个，你知道的，“我知道什么是亲爱的”，然后还有像书名一样的桥段，比如今天我们做完这个之后要播出的那一集，有一个从外面拍医院的镜头，就像比斯坎湾医院，我总是说“比斯坎湾的波浪是多么黑暗”，但是珍，你觉得呢？对不起，帕特里克，是的，什么？对不起大家，对不起，什么是隐喻？别，别担心，我一点也不担心，好吧。我还特别喜欢——我知道我们现在思绪乱飞——我喜欢芭芭拉有多势利，还有她的胸针，你知道的，那是她在摩洛哥发现的，现在她再也没有作家散步的机会了。我就觉得，然后我喜欢这种挖苦。是，是罗斯还是我们的布兰奇说你不能穿格子图案的？我太喜欢了。然后我喜欢当有人很势利却故意把名字叫错。就像她一直叫她“麦奇”，这简直太
snarky and passive aggressive. And intentional, right? Like she's, the character's, literally doing it up. It's such a nasty move. There was a girl when I went to college that when she didn't like someone, she would purposely get their name wrong. And it was a whole thing we all picked up on. So like, if your name was Betsy, she'd be like, hi, Bet. I'm like, bet.
刻薄和被动攻击了。而且是故意的，对吧？就像她，这个角色简直就是故意的。这太讨厌了。我上大学时有个女孩，当她不喜欢某人的时候，她会故意把人家的名字叫错。这成了我们所有人都会模仿的一个梗。所以，如果你叫贝茨，她就会说，嗨，贝。我就想，贝？
Since when you called me, Bet? Or she'd be like, seriously, you'd be like Amy. And she'd be like, hi, Emil. And you're like, a meal. Like, what? She would just get like a few letters off. And I'm like, oh, she is so damn snarky. Ew.
从什么时候起你叫我贝了？或者她会说，真的，如果你叫埃米。她就会说，嗨，埃米尔。你会想，埃米尔？什么鬼？她就是会把几个字母念错，然后我就想，哦，她太特么刻薄了。呃。
Yeah. My other question, like, in my opinion. opinion, one of the things that makes that show work so well is the guest star. And so I wanted to talk to you about your experiences working with guest stars, you know, whether like memorable experiences on the office that worked great or ones that didn't. And if you all were ever guest stars, like what your experience was. Yeah. I mean, the person who comes to mind is Amy Adams, who came in very early on in our first season as a guest star and just crushed it with the, like type of acting that you had to do and the looking at camera or not looking at camera. And, you know, Amy Adams wasn't marquee Amy Adams when she did our show. Yeah.
是的。我的另一个问题，就像，在我看来。依我之见，让那部剧如此成功的因素之一就是客串明星。所以我想和你聊聊你与客串明星合作的经历，你知道的，比如在《办公室》里有哪些难忘的经历，哪些效果绝佳，或者哪些不太好。以及如果你们曾经客串过，你们的经历是怎样的。好吧。我的脑海里浮现出的第一个人是艾米·亚当斯，她在我们第一季的时候很早就作为客串明星出场了，她简直完美驾驭了你必须要做的那种表演，比如看着镜头还是不看着镜头。而且，你知道的，艾米·亚当斯在演我们的剧时还不是那种超级大牌的艾米·亚当斯。对。
After she filmed... She wasn't even nominated for her first Academy Award yet. No, no, I hadn't even come out yet. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So that was crazy. And then what was so freaking cool about her was that she did her first episode.
在她拍完……她当时甚至还没有获得她的第一次奥斯卡提名呢。不，不，那部电影甚至都还没上映呢。对。对。对。所以这太疯狂了。然后她最酷的地方在于，她演完了她的第一季客串，
And then in the second season, when she was now Academy Award nominee Amy Adams and like being like courted for all the biggest movies, she was like, yeah, I'll come back and I'll do like four lines in an episode and then I'll go sit on a boat for three days in the middle of the night and don't boost crews with the eyes. Like she was just like so cool and up for it even as her star was like skyrocketing, you know?
然后到了第二季，当她已经成了奥斯卡提名的艾米·亚当斯，各大电影争相邀约的时候，她却说：“好吧，我回来客串四句台词，然后我要去大半夜在船上坐三天，别管阿汤哥的眼睛了。”她就是这么酷，而且完全乐意配合，尽管她的星途正在像火箭般腾飞，你知道吗？
That's cool. She said in an interview somewhere, she's like, you couldn't have kept me away. She's like, I would have taken time off from whatever I was doing to go back. That was clear. That was clear. And, you know, for the threat level midnight episode, they reached out to her because they really, you know, the idea was that he had been filming threat level midnight for years. And there would be, like, scenes with, like, people who you'd seen years ago on the office.
这太酷了。她在某个采访中说过，她当时说：“你们根本拦不住我。”她说：“不管我在忙什么，我都会腾出时间回去。”这很明显。这真的很明显。而且，你知道的，为了“威胁等级：午夜”那一集，他们联系了她，因为他们真的，你知道，当时的想法是迈克尔已经拍了多年的“威胁等级：午夜”。里面会有一些场景，比如那些你几年前在《办公室》里见过的演员。
And they really wanted her in, like, a flashback scene. And she wanted to do it so bad. and I can't remember the reason why Ange, right? But, like, she was on a movie. She was, like, in another city. She was like, I'll take a red eye. I'll do it. And, like, the movie wouldn't let her out.
他们真的很想让她出现在某个闪回的场景里。她超级想演。我记不清原因了，安吉，对吧？但是，她当时在拍一部电影。她当时在另一个城市。她说：“我坐红眼航班去。我来拍。”但是电影公司不放人。
Like, she was like, I want to do this so badly. Yeah. Now, Jenna, you just called Angela Ange. Does that mean you don't like her? No, are we good? That's a nickname. Nicknames are allowed. Okay, that's allowed.
就像她当时说：“我太想演这个了。”对。现在，珍，你刚才叫安吉拉作“安吉”。这是否意味着你不喜欢她？不，我们关系很好吧？这是一个昵称。昵称是可以被允许的。好吧，这没问题。
Okay. Full-on, not your name, snark. Yes. A little smart. Yeah. I hope people called her by the wrong name, just to tie it in a bow. Yes. No, Angela, do you have a guest star that you remember working with that stands out as a memorable experience good or bad?
好吧。完全不叫真名，是挖苦。是的。带点俏皮。对。我希望人们都叫错她的名字，好让这个梗首尾呼应。对。不，安吉拉，你有没有哪个客串明星让你印象深刻，无论是好是坏？
I mean. And if it's bad, you don't have to say their name. Oh, no, no. I mean, just memorable. Like, when I think of someone who walked on the set and it was like electricity went through the room, it's Idris Elba. I mean, when he walked on the stage. Electricity just went through the room at the mere mention of the name. Everybody was just like, oh, hi.
我是说。如果是不好的，你不用说出他们的名字。哦，不，不。我是说，只要是难忘的就行。比如，当我想起有谁走进片场时，那种感觉就像一股电流穿过整个房间，那就是伊德瑞斯·埃尔巴。我是说，当他走进片场时。仅仅提到这个名字，一股电流就穿过了整个房间。每个人都像是，哦，嗨。
Like it was, he was so charming and he totally got his character. He knew exactly who Charles was. He was like amazing and went toe to toe with everyone and then was also incredibly charming. So, yeah, that is one. And he really did. It translates into the episode because it's like that was his character. Like everyone was just like swooning all around him like in the episode. Yeah.
就好像是，他太有魅力了，而且他完全理解他的角色。他清楚地知道查尔斯是谁。他简直棒极了，能和所有人针锋相对，同时又极具个人魅力。所以，是的，这是其中之一。而且他确实做到了。这完美地转化到了剧集里，因为那正是他的角色。就像剧里那样，所有人都围着他神魂颠倒。对。
I would feel like walking on to our stage at that point because, you know, you. You know, when we talked about Amy Adams, that was early in the show. But now this is later in the show. It's very established. The characters are established. And to walk in as a guest star then, I feel like would have been really intimidating. I would have been intimidated. And he was just, he was there, man.
我觉得走到我们的片场在那个时候，因为，你知道，你。你知道的，当我们谈到艾米·亚当斯时，那是在剧集早期。但现在这是在剧集后期。已经非常成熟了。角色都已经深入人心了。在那时候作为客串明星走进来，我觉得会非常有压力的。我会感到很有压力。但他就是，他一到那就直接进入状态了，伙计。
He was ready to go. You know, something about the office that was very unique to our show was that we all had to be there all day every day because we were in the background of each other's scenes. The bullpen was open. So if you were a guest star, you had to be ready for that. You had, like, that comes with the job. And I cannot tell you how many humongous stars, Kathy Bates, Idris Elba. Timothy Alphant.
他已经准备好开工了。你知道，《办公室》里有一点对我们的剧来说非常独特，那就是我们大家必须整天都在片场，因为我们要出现在彼此场景的背景里。开放式办公区是互通的。所以如果你是一个客串明星，你必须为此做好准备。你得，这本就是工作的一部分。而且我无法告诉你到底有多少超级大巨星，凯西·贝茨，伊德瑞斯·埃尔巴。蒂莫西·奥利芬特。
Yes. You know, Will Farrell, you know, came through our doors and just what incredible artists they were because they were like, yeah, I'll sit here for four hours. while you guys figure out a scene in front of my desk. We were so lucky with our guest stars. You know, someone who popped in my head who just absolutely delighted me was Andy Daly as Ben Franklin. Oh, he's so good.
是的。你知道的，威尔·法瑞尔，你知道的，都曾走进我们的大门，他们是多么不可思议的艺术家，因为他们会说：“好吧，我愿意在这里坐上四个小时，看着你们在我的办公桌前琢磨一场戏。”我们能有这些客串明星真是太幸运了。你知道的，有一个人突然浮现在我的脑海里，她绝对让我感到惊喜，那就是饰演本·富兰克林的安迪·戴利。哦，他太棒了。
He's been Franklin. I couldn't get through those scenes with him. Like, so funny. Yes. You know, it's just popping into my mind, and I'm sure she doesn't count as a guest star, but there is another Golden Girls' The Office crossover, and I wonder if you know this. Malora Hardin. I was going to guess, Melora.
他就是本·富兰克林。我简直没法跟他一起拍完那些戏。太搞笑了。是的。你知道的，这突然跳进我的脑海里，虽然她肯定算不上客串明星，但还有另一个《黄金女郎》与《办公室》的联动，我在想你知道不知道。梅洛拉·哈丁。我本来想猜的，梅洛拉。
I mean, you know, we just like... Malora was on Golden Girls? No, her dad was. Her dad played... I know. I think his name is Jerry Hardin, and he played the professor that sexually harassed Blanche.
我是说，你知道的，我们只是……梅洛拉演过《黄金女郎》吗？没有，她爸爸演过。她爸爸演的是……我知道。我想他叫杰瑞·哈丁，他演了那个对布兰奇进行性骚扰的教授。
Do you remember that episode? Yes, that was Malora's dad? Yeah. And that's Malora's dad. And I, when we were doing a deep dive on it, and I waited till the end, I'm like, Jen, you're going to die when I tell you who, like, who he's related to. I think his name is Jerry Hardin.
你还记得那一集吗？对，那是梅洛拉的爸爸？对。那是梅洛拉的爸爸。然后我，当我们深入研究这个的时候，我一直憋到最后才说，我当时想：“珍，当我告诉你他是谁的亲戚时，你一定会惊掉下巴的。”我想他叫杰瑞·哈丁。
And it's funny if you look at him, he looks just like her. Like, you can see, like, you can, like, see her face on him. I do remember that you found him attractive. Listen, I didn't want to be controversial and be like, oh, the guy who sexually harassed Blanche is hot, but, like, Malara Hardin's dad's kind of hot. I mean, Malara is gorgeous. She's beautiful. And the only reason why she came to mind is because of everyone on the show, I feel like Malora had the biggest acting pedigree as far as generational, you know? Like, she grew up acting.
有趣的是，如果你看着他，他长得跟她一模一样。就像你能看到，你能在他身上看到她的脸。我确实记得你觉得他很有吸引力。听着，我本来不想引起争议，说“对布兰奇进行性骚扰的家伙很性感”，但是，梅洛拉·哈丁的爸爸确实挺性感的。我是说，梅洛拉美极了。她太漂亮了。她之所以出现在我的脑海里，是因为在剧组所有人中，我觉得梅洛拉有着最深厚的演艺世家背景，从世代演艺的角度来说，你知道吗？就像她从小就开始演戏了。
I knew her family. Her dad was in the business. Her mom was a manager and a teacher and an acting coach. Malara was on Little House on the Prairie. Yeah. She was. Yes. Yes.
我认识她的家人。她爸爸在这个圈子里。她妈妈是经纪人、老师兼表演教练。梅洛拉演过《草原小屋》。对。她演过。对。对。
It's so funny because I am not an actor. I don't really understand the hierarchy of what a set is like. But I understand that you all are like the stars. And then, you know, Malora Hardin comes in and she's a guest star or whatever. But her, Jan felt like everybody's boss. And it really felt like you all were afraid of her. Like it translated into so far as like, we know they're acting. We know this isn't real.
太有趣了，因为我不是演员。我其实不太懂片场阶级的层级关系。但我知道你们是主演。然后，你知道的，梅洛拉·哈丁进来了，她是个客串明星什么的。但是她，简给人的感觉就像是所有人的老板。而且真的让人觉得你们都有点怕她。这种感觉甚至渗透到了——虽然我们知道大家是在演戏。我们知道这不是真的。
But I can't imagine they actually like her because she's so mean. You know, like she was so perfect. And it was also lived in it. And I was thinking about what you were saying about the guest stars being like Kathy Bates, being like, sure, I'll come in and figure, watch you guys. I bet that was so fun for them. Like the office. And this is kind of a question.
但我无法想象你们真的会喜欢她，因为她太刻薄了。你知道的，就像她表现得太完美了。而且她完全融入其中。我在想你刚才说的那些客串明星，比如凯西·贝茨，会说：“没问题，我来这儿坐着看你们演。”我敢打赌这对他们来说一定很有趣。就像《办公室》一样。这其实算是一个问题。
Like, were you able to realize how iconic it was while you were doing it? Because I would think even when you're a Kathy Bates or a James Bader or an interest Selba, they get to come and play in that world for a week or however long it is. And maybe did you recognize that even though they were big stars, that you were big stars and that like them getting to watch you work was probably really fun for them. It's so funny. We interviewed Kathy Bates for office ladies. And she talked about how intimidated she was.
你们在拍摄的时候，能够意识到它有多么经典吗？因为我觉得哪怕你已经是凯西·贝茨、詹姆斯·贝德或者伊德瑞斯·埃尔巴，他们来到这个世界里玩上一周或不管多久，也许你们有没有意识到，尽管他们是大明星，但你们也是大明星，而且他们能看着你们工作可能对他们来说真的很有趣？太搞笑了。我们为《办公室女士》采访了凯西·贝茨。她谈到了她当时有多么紧张。
And we were like, wait, what? I know. I know. It's wild. Yeah. I just love that you shared how game these. actors were to sit there on set and not, you know, have someone stand in for them or just wait in their trailer or their room. It's just such a reminder and a lesson to be just a team
我们当时都惊呆了，心想：等等，什么？我知道。我知道。这太疯狂了。是的。我只是很喜欢你分享了这些演员是多么乐意坐在片场，而不是（你知道的）找替身代演，或者只在他们的房车或休息室里干等着。这真是一个很好的提醒和一课，告诉我们要成为一个团队
player and to have fun and not not take it so seriously and just to have fun, you know, and be a good, be a nice person, be someone people want to work with. It's really lovely to hear that. Well, to be fair, we were a fun place to work. Like, you didn't want to be in your trailer, you know, you were going to miss out on something because we were, if we weren't doing a hilarious scene, we were doing bits off camera and having the best time. So you did not want to be in your trailer. There are some sets where you're like,
精神，要玩得开心，不要太严肃，只要享受乐趣，你知道的，做一个好人，做一个别人愿意跟她合作的人。听到这些真的很美好。好吧，公平地说，我们本来就是一个充满乐趣的工作场所。就像，你根本不想待在房车里，你知道的，因为那样你会错过一些精彩瞬间，因为如果我们不是在拍搞笑的戏，我们就会在镜头外疯狂抛梗，玩得不亦乐乎。所以你才不想待在房车里呢。有些剧组你会觉得，
I'm going to need to go to my trailer. Yeah, yeah, yeah, sure. Toxicity happening that I want to get away from. Yeah. But all of these big stars, we were a really artistically satisfying place to be, I think. I love that. I want to get to more listener questions,
我得回我的房车去了。对，对，对，没错。里面充满了有毒的氛围，我想逃离。是的。但是所有这些大明星，我认为我们是一个在艺术上非常令人满足的地方。我喜欢这样。我想聊聊更多听众提问，
but I would be remiss if I didn't tell you, Jenna, that like, Pam, you're missing things is the thing that my husband and I scream at each other whenever one of us is not in the room that they need to be. And do you remember that episode? It was like the episode at the lake. No.
但如果我不告诉你一件事，那我可就太失职了，珍——那就是，“潘，你漏掉东西了”这句话，每当我和我丈夫中有一人不在他们该在的房间时，我们俩都会冲对方大喊。你还记得那一集吗？就像湖边那一集。不。
Oh, my God. It is so iconic in our house. Refresh my memory. Is Michael? Was Michael the one that said it? Yeah, it's Michael from off camera because it was like the vacation day where you all go to the lake
哦，天哪。在我们家里这简直太经典了。帮我回忆一下。是迈克尔吗？是迈克尔在镜头外说的吗？对，那是你们所有人去湖边的那个假期
and you, but like you didn't get to have a vacation because you had to like walk around and write down what everybody was doing. Yes, I had to tear knowledge and notes. Yes. And so there's a shot right before it goes into the commercial where you're like talking to the camera and you're just kind of like I just wanted to like come to the beat. And from off camera you hear Michael go, Pam, you're missing things.
而你，但你好像根本没能去度假，因为你得四处走动，记下每个人在干什么。对，我得记下知识和笔记。对。就在切入广告前有一个镜头，是你对着镜头说话，你差不多就是说我只想来合拍。然后能听到画外音迈克尔说：“帕姆，你漏掉东西了。”
And it is, I have watched it so many times. And my husband and I just like scream it down the hallway to each other. And then Angela, of course, save Bandit. Like, do people just shout that at you in parking lots? Yes. People yell Save Bandit. And then, you know, for me, because I get saved Bandit a lot, I know Jenna gets, please don't throw garbage at my head. Is that what you get, Jenna? Please don't throw garbage at me. Please don't throw garbage at me. And then I have gotten green as hoarse, but the one that like I always remember because I was like, what?
而且，我看了它无数次。我和我丈夫经常在走廊里冲对方大喊。然后安吉拉当然是“救救班迪特”。话说，人们会在停车场对你大喊这个吗？是的。人们会大喊“救救班迪特”。然后，你知道，对我和珍娜来说，我知道珍娜经常听到的是“请不要把垃圾扔到我头上”。是这样吗，珍娜？“请不要向我扔垃圾。”“请不要向我扔垃圾。”然后我还听过“绿色如马”，但我总是记得其中一个，因为当时我在想：什么？
I had gone to see you two and I was walking to my seats. I was going down a staircase and you know the section right above you, like the balcony. As I'm going down, these young guys come to the edge of the balcony and they yell across. the section, Angela, I would take the Da Vinci Code so I could burn the Da Vinci Code. And that's like such a random thing. And I was like, oh my gosh, right. That's when we all say what we would take in the deserted island. I mean, it's also the other one that we say to each other all the time is a glass of warm milk, two chapters of a good book, and lights out by nine. That's how I sleep at night. That's such a good one. Yeah. All right. Do you,
我曾去看 U2 乐队的演出，当时我正走向座位。我正在下一段楼梯，你知道就在你头顶上方那个区域，比如包厢。当我走下去的时候，几个年轻小伙子走到包厢边缘，隔着整个区域大喊：安吉拉，我要带上《达芬奇密码》，这样我就可以烧掉《达芬奇密码》。这真是太随机了。当时我想：哦，天哪，对。那是我们所有人都在说如果流落荒岛会带什么的时候。我的意思是，这也是我们经常对彼此说的另一句话：一杯温牛奶，两章好书，九点熄灯。我晚上就是这么睡觉的。这真是太棒了。对。好吧。你们，
You have time for a couple more listener questions? Sure. We have tons of time. Yeah, we're here. Oh, my God. I love you guys. Okay, so we're officially making a podcast together. So Jessica says, I would love to know where they would live if they could move and live like the Golden Girls.
你们有时间回答几个听众提问吗？当然。我们有的是时间。对，我们就在这。哦，天哪。我爱你们。好的，所以我们正在正式一起制作播客。杰西卡说，我很想知道如果她们能搬家并像《黄金女郎》那样生活，她们会住在哪里。
I think it'd be funny to see an episode with Angela, Pam, Kelly, and Phyllis in a house for a weekend. Oh, my gosh. That's the spin-off we need. That is the spin-off. That would be so good. Where would the house be? and what do you think that, like, what would the situation be? I don't know, but Meredith definitely lives next door.
我觉得看一集安吉拉、帕姆、凯利和菲莉丝在一个房子里度过周末会很有趣。哦，天哪。这就是我们需要的外传。那就是那个外传。那太棒了。房子会建在哪里？你觉得会是怎样的情况？我不知道，但梅雷迪思绝对住在隔壁。
Yeah. We won't let her live with us, but she's, like, moved adjacent to us. Maybe she's in the garage apartment. Yes. Yes. I love it. Here's a question I love. If you two could have guest starred on an episode of the Golden Girls, which one would it have been?
对。我们不会让她和我们住在一起，但她就像是搬到了我们隔壁。也许她住在车库公寓里。对。对。我喜欢。这里有一个我最喜欢的问题。如果你们两个能在《黄金女郎》的一集中客串，你们会选哪一集？
Oh, I don't know them well enough. I wish I did. Or if you could be a character, like, if you could even, That's what we always ask. Yeah. Who would you be? Yeah, which golden girl would you say you are and which one would your friends say you are? Oh, that's a good one.
哦，我对它们不够了解。但愿我很了解。或者如果你能扮演一个角色，比如如果你甚至，这就是我们经常问的。对。你会是谁？对，你会说你是哪个黄金女郎，你的朋友又会说你是哪个？哦，这是个好问题。
Well, I know who you would say I am. Dorothy? Yes. Yes. Dorothy is a Bornaq. Yes. Am I rose, Jenna? Yes.
好吧，我知道你会说我是谁。多萝西？对。对。多萝西是个天生的人。对。我是露丝吗，珍娜？对。
You are. I am Rose. You are. Although I know a Malamar is a cookie. Right. Yeah, that's so funny. You know, if I could go on the Golden Girls and be in one episode, I would want to be there the day that Bert Reynolds shows up to the front door.
你是。我是露丝。你是。虽然我知道马拉玛是一种饼干。对。对，太搞笑 了。你知道的，如果我能去《黄金女郎》并出演一集，我想成为伯特·雷诺兹出现在前门的那一天的那个人。
Oh, my God. And so, me, it's just like, hey, Mark, we're off to lunch or whatever. And everyone else is like, what? I mean, talk about, like, a great door opener guest. It's so good. And the line is, he leans into Sophia, which wants the slug? And they all raise their hands. It's so good.
哦，天哪。所以对我来说，就像是，嘿，马克，我们要去吃午饭什么的。而其他人则说：什么？我是说，说到一个很棒的开门客串。真是太棒了。台词是，他靠向索菲亚：“哪个想要接吻？”然后他们都举起了手。真是太棒了。
All right, this is a good one. If they could have a mashup between the two shows, which two characters would you love to have a scene together? My two requests would be Meredith and Blanche and then Dwight and Sophia. Oh, yeah. I mean, I also think Michael with any of them, really and truly, have a sit down with Michael with any one of those ladies, and that would be off to the races.
好吧，这是一个好问题。如果两部剧可以进行跨界联动，你最希望哪两个角色一起演对手戏？我的两个要求是梅雷迪思和布兰奇，然后是德怀特和索菲亚。哦，对。我的意思是，我也觉得迈克尔和她们中的任何一个人在一起，真的和真正地，让迈克尔和这些女士中的任何一个坐下来谈谈，那绝对会一发不可收拾。
Like, Michael and Rose would be some really good content, I think. I could also see Michael on a date with Blanche because she would blow his mind. And he did date Pam's mom. Exactly. Right. Yeah, yeah. Oh, true. Wait, here's a last question from Heidi.
比如迈克尔和露丝会碰撞出非常精彩的内容，我觉得。我还能想象迈克尔和布兰奇约会，因为她会把他惊艳到。而且他确实和帕姆的妈妈约会过。完全正确。对，对。哦，真的。等等，这是海蒂提出的最后一个问题。
It says, if Pam and Angela were to show up on the Golden Girls, what would they look like? Are they related to someone? Are they neighbors charity event? Like Mrs. Claxton. Are they neighbors charity event? Maybe they're on a business trip to the Sabre headquarters. Oh, I think in my heart of hearts, we'd be neighbors, and we would be those ladies that do the same walk every morning, you know? Like, I have these two ladies that live at the end of my street.
上面写着，如果帕姆和安吉拉出现在《黄金女郎》里，她们会是什么样子？她们和某人有亲戚关系吗？她们是参加慈善活动的邻居吗？就像克拉克斯顿夫人那样。她们是参加慈善活动的邻居吗？也许她们是去萨博总部出差。哦，我觉得在我内心深处，我们会是邻居，我们会成为那种每天早上都散步的女士，你知道吗？就像我街尾住着这样两个女士。
They're side by side. They're widowers. They do this walk. And one day, I had lived in my house 10 years. And one day they walked by and they said, oh, it's so nice you finally got your fence done. I was like, how long has this bothered them? How many times? That's, in my heart of hearts, Jenna and I would be these two gals that walk by and say, like, comment on people's yards.
她们并肩而行。她们都是寡妇。她们会这样散步。有一天，我在我家住了10年。有一天她们走过来说：“哦，你终于把栅栏弄好了，真好。”当时我想：这事困扰她们多久了？多少次了？这就是，在我内心深处，珍娜和我就会是那种走过去并对别人的院子评头论足的姑娘。
I love it. Oh, my God. I love it. I have a question after watching this episode. Please. Which, yes, which is so a big theme in this episode is like first impressions. Like, you know, Barbara makes this really great first impression, but then it's not lasting. But then she has, you know, she talks about how like, well, maybe I just got a bad impression.
我太喜欢了。哦，天哪。我太喜欢了。看完这一集我有个问题。请说。这集的很大一个主题就是第一印象。比如，你知道，芭芭拉留下了非常棒的第一印象，但这种印象并不持久。然后她有，你知道，她谈到比如，好吧，也许我只是留下了不好的印象。
first impression of your friends. I'll give them another try. Do you guys remember your first impression of one another? That is so a, it's so kind of you to ask us a question. I, if I may, Miss Simard. So Jennifer Samard is a huge Broadway star. She's a three-time Tony nominee. She's co-starring and Death Becomes her on Broadway right now. She's got her third time nomination. If you go to her, did you, are you guys? Are you guys on TikTok? Do you like follow the trends? We're not on the tickety talk, but we're, we're, we might get on it. I don't I don't know. Jennifer, can I, I have to like pause right now. Yes. I saw death becomes her with my mom and I did not connect those dots. Holy shit. You're amazing. Oh, thank you, Jenna. Oh, my God. Yeah. Thank you. It is a triumph and you are so freaking funny. Thank you. And I saw you on the Tony's in your seat with your little sign. Yes. My little sign. Yes. That's the ticket. Talk Patrick's referring to because that
对你朋友的第一印象。我会再给他们一次机会。你们还记得彼此的第一印象吗？真是太，你问我们这样一个问题太客气了。如果可以的话，西马尔女士。所以珍妮弗·西马尔是一位百老汇巨星。她是三次托尼奖提名者。她目前正在百老汇联合主演《飞越来世》。她获得了第三次提名。如果你去她的，你，你们在吗？你们在玩 TikTok 吗？你们会关注潮流吗？我们不玩那个滴答吐涛，但我们，我们可能会玩。我不知道。珍妮弗，我能不能，我现在得暂停一下。对。我和我妈妈一起看了《飞越来世》，我当时没把这些联系起来。天哪。你太棒了。哦，谢谢你，珍娜。哦，天哪。对。谢谢你。这是一场伟大的胜利，而且你太搞笑了吧。谢谢你。而且我在托尼奖颁奖典礼上看到你坐在座位上，手里拿着你的小牌子。对。我的小牌子。对。这就是帕特里克提到的那个滴答吐涛，因为那
That's from the show That was rude And that went viral And there's this There's this video of Bette Midler Who's a friend of Jens Coming backstage after the show And Bet Midler on her knees
那是来自节目的那太粗鲁了那个在网上疯传了然后有这个有这个视频是贝特·米德勒她是詹的朋友演出结束后到后台来贝特·米德勒单膝跪地
Bowing to Jennifer Like saying like how Wait is that online Yeah It's on my Instagram No I don't know how Because you know you get like the algorithms I saw that
向珍妮弗鞠躬就像是说“天哪，这能在网上看到吗？”对。在我的Instagram上。不，我不知道怎么弄，因为你知道你会遇到算法之类的。我看到了那个
And I was like damn I mean Wait a second Are you going to on stage tonight? Yes. Yes, I am. Oh my gosh, Jen. Yes. Well, thank you for hopping on and talking with us. She's been doing this the whole time. Let me tell you. Like, Jen, we've been making, we're, we've been making this podcast as long as she's been doing Death Becomes Her. Like, she is, she is such a rock star. Why would I give up the opportunity to meet incredible humans such as yourself?
当时我想：天哪。我是说。等等。你今晚要上台吗？对。对，我要上台。哦，天哪，詹。对。好吧，谢谢你加入我们并和我们聊天。她一直都在这么做。我跟你说。就像，詹，我们制作，我们制作这个播客的时间和她出演《飞越来世》的时间一样长。就像，她，她绝对是个摇滚巨星。我怎么能放弃结识像你这样不可思议的人类的机会呢？
Oh my gosh. Jen, I'm so, I'll sleep when I'm dead. I'm so humbled because, I mean, Jen, Jen, Jen, and I both just, we know what it takes to do a podcast and show up and that energy and to know that you're also then going to go out on stage tonight. Thank you so much for taking the time out from your preparation. I know. My mind is blown right now. Thank you very much. I don't know how I didn't put that together before. No, because you know why we're all, just we're, I think every actress is inherently a character actress. You have to disappear into that part, you know. So I, I know that's, you wouldn't know me if you saw me on the street half the time. So I take it as a compliment to be perfectly honest.
哦，天哪。詹，我太，我死后才能睡。我感到非常荣幸，因为，我的意思是，詹，詹，詹，我们俩都知道制作一个播客并出镜需要付出什么，那种活力，而且知道你今晚还要上台表演。非常感谢你抽出准备的时间。我懂的。我现在脑子里一片空白。非常感谢。我不知道我之前怎么没把这些联系起来。不，因为你知道为什么我们所有人，就是我们，我觉得每个女演员本质上都是性格演员。你必须融入那个角色，你知道的。所以，我，我知道，如果你在大街上看到我，有一半时间你认不出我。所以老实说，我把它当作一种赞美。
Well, I saw the show with my mom and my mom and I were just like, I can't believe we got to see those two ladies on stage. We feel so privileged. That's the cool thing about theater, you know. You either see it or you don't. And it's a moment in time, although I have a feeling this is going to be a real long moment because, I mean, you know. It's very good. It's very good. But, wow.
好吧，我和我妈妈一起看了演出，我和我妈妈当时就觉得，真不敢相信我们能在舞台上看到这两位女士。我们感到非常荣幸。这就是戏剧的酷炫之处，你知道的。你要么看到了，要么没看到。这是时光中的一个瞬间，虽然我有一种预感，这将是一个非常漫长的瞬间，因为，我的意思是，你知道。非常精彩。非常精彩。但是，哇。
Wow. That was it. I mean, I was a fan of Jen's from years and years and years ago. And then over the pandemic, I found out that Jen was listening to my other, I make a true crime podcast as well. And Jen was like a listener to that podcast. And so I was blown away by that. And so I reached, I like slid into her DMs. I'm like, hi, I love you. Like, thank you for listening. And we went back and forth. And then she started coming over. I think I slid into your DMs because, you know, True Crime Obsessed is a hugely successful podcast. And a girlfriend in mine wanted to do one of our own during the pandemic and you were so kind to information share. But my first impression of Patrick was one of incredible competence and exuberance and genuine excitement and kindness because I was a guest on his theater people podcast back in 2016. And then friends of mine wanted to start a podcast with me. I guess I've been doing it for seven years since 2018. And this venture with Patrick is my third venture And my favorite to date
哇。就是这样。我是说，我多年来一直都是詹的粉丝。然后在疫情期间，我发现詹在听我的另一个节目，我也制作了一个真实犯罪播客。詹居然是那个播客的听众。这让我大为震撼。所以我联系了她，我滑进她的私信。我说：嗨，我爱你们。谢谢你收听。我们聊了很多。然后她开始过来。我想是我滑进你的私信的，因为你知道，“沉迷真实犯罪”是一个非常成功的播客。疫情期间，我的一个女友想自己做一个，而你非常慷慨地分享了信息。但我对帕特里克的第一印象是难以置信的能力、热情、真诚的兴奋和善良，因为我曾在2016年做过他“戏剧人物”播客的嘉宾。然后我的朋友们想和我一起开始一个播客。我想自从2018年以来我已经做七年了。这次和帕特里克的合作是我的第三次尝试，也是我迄今为止最喜欢的。
But I wanted to thank you for that question But it was like you guys were Your first impressions of each other Came from your work, from your artistry From your admiration of each other's work Has like an artist crush on one another Yes, truly But isn't it interesting that Rose and Blanche's first impression
但我还是要感谢你提出那个问题，不过就像你们对彼此的第一印象来自于你们的工作、你们的艺术创作、来自对彼此作品的欣赏，就像对彼此有艺术上的崇拜。是的，真的。但这难道不有趣吗？露丝和布兰奇的第一印象
Was the accurate one, so to speak Do you know what I mean? About who Barbara was to her quote? and something else. So Mark Cherry is a friend of the podcast. I heard his interview. Okay. So you heard what he said.
可以说是准确的，对吧？你知道我的意思吗？关于芭芭拉对她来说引用了什么？还有别的。所以马克·切里是本播客的朋友。我听过他的采访。好的。所以你听过他说的了。
And he said the thing about Rue McClanahan is how good she was at playing all the different colors of a character. And she could play in quotes. She could play a quote dumb. And I see or just kind of flighty. And I see that color in her in this episode. She's just so good at all those different nuances. But the theme that you talk about, so that really affects. you, Jenna, the theme of this episode.
他谈到鲁·麦克拉纳汉时说，她非常擅长扮演一个角色的所有不同色彩。她可以“引号”她可以“引号”装傻。或者只是有点轻浮。我在这一集的她身上看到了这种色彩。她对所有这些不同的细微差别都处理得太好了。但你谈到的那个主题，真的深深影响了你，珍娜，这一集的主题。
That's part of it. Yeah. What's interesting to me is that it made me reflect because, you know, at the end, Blanche and Rose's assessment of Barbara is correct that she's a crappy person. But it made me reflect about how in my relationship with Angela, we've each had different, like, friends that we've brought into our lives that we like. And every once in a while, there's someone that Angela and I are like, huh, really? Like, Angela will make a new friend and I'll be like, I don't care for her.
那是其中的一部分。对。对我有趣的是，这让我进行反思，因为，你知道，最后，布兰奇和露丝对芭芭拉的评估是正确的，她是个糟糕的人。但这让我反思，我和安吉拉的关系中，我们各自带进生活并喜欢的朋友。每隔一段时间，就会有这样一个人，让安吉拉和我产生这样的想法：哈，真的吗？比如安吉拉会交到一个新朋友，而我会说：我不太喜欢她。
And the other way around. And then other times there's people where I'm like, oh, my gosh, she's a peach. I love her. What a gem of a person. And it's kind of interesting to me because after I watched this episode and I was thinking about it. And I said it to you, Angela, I was like, have you noticed that the ones that the other person didn't like, they didn't actually stick around. Yeah.
反之亦然。有时也会有这样的人，我会说：哦，天哪，她太棒了。我喜欢她。多好的一块美玉啊。这对我来说挺有趣的，因为在我看完这一集并思考之后。我对你说了，安吉拉，我说：你有没有注意到，对方不喜欢的人，其实最终都没有留下来。对。
Oh, interesting. Like, but not like in such a confrontational way or anything, but just a kind of like, huh. Like you didn't say go to hell. No, and I didn't say you can't be friends with her. I just said, I don't love her. Yeah. Or vice versa. Or you might just have that moment where you're like, hmm, okay, okay.
哦，有趣。就像，但不是以那种对抗性的方式，而是一种“哈”的感觉。就像你没有说“去死吧”。没有，我也没有说“你不能和她做朋友”。我只是说“我不太喜欢她”。对。或者反过来。或者你可能只是会有那种时刻，让你觉得：嗯，好吧，好吧。
And then there's no like, I told you so, there's none of that. It's just how it just plays out. We're getting into a deep area here. This excites me. Let me ask you this question to the groom. Because we all have that shiny object syndrome in friendship. Since like when you're little kids, too, you're like you have your really good rider dies. And then some popular kid likes you and you kind of dump the other kid for a minute. And it's not the best quality, but we all understand what that's like. You know how psychologists or psychiatrists or therapists will say we're often drawn to a romantic partner that is tapping into some unhealed wound from our past? There's an attraction there. Maybe because of, not always, but because there might be some unhealed trauma. Do you think the same is true with some of these friendships that don't work out, that the attraction is so strong because they are a reflection of something you need to grow or look at? Just hypothetically, I'm sure it's not always that way. I think maybe.
然后没有什么“我早就告诉你了”，完全没有那些。事情就是这样自然发展。我们在这里探讨得很深奥。这让我很兴奋。我问你们这个问题，新人们。因为我们在友情中都有那种“闪亮物品综合征”。就像当你还是小孩子的时候，你会有你最好的生死之交。然后某个受欢迎的小孩喜欢你，你就会把另一个小孩冷落一会儿。这并不是最好的品质，但我们都理解那是怎么回事。你知道为什么心理学家、精神病学家或治疗师会说，我们常常会被一个能够触及我们过去某种未愈合创伤的浪漫伴侣所吸引吗？那里有一种吸引力。也许是因为，并非总是如此，但也可能是因为存在一些未愈合的创伤。你认为这些行不通的友谊也是如此吗？这种吸引力如此强烈，是因为它们反映了你需要成长或审视的某种东西？只是假设，我敢肯定并非总是如此。我想也许吧。
I also think sometimes whatever your childhood trauma is, you get drawn to it because it's familiar. And then you have to be reminded that you don't want that. Yeah. And then sometimes you get drawn into relationships that heal, you know, that give you the opposite, you know, like my friendship with Angela is a healing friendship. You know, it's just a friendship of unconditional love and trust and support and all those things. And it heals me every day. I just love it so much. But, you know, like you said, the shiny object is, oh my gosh, go back to my early dating life. I mean, how much. much like I would be attracted to, I don't want to say, but you know, just like, I do, not the right person because it was familiar, you know, but it wasn't the healthiest thing. Yeah. Do you all follow Dr. Romney? She's a doctor who, she does a lot of like work around like narcissism and childhood trauma and stuff. And one of the things that she had a guest on her podcast and she said,
我也认为有时无论你的童年创伤是什么，你都会被它吸引，因为它很熟悉。然后你不得不被提醒，你并不想要那个。对。然后有时你会卷入能治愈你的关系中，你知道，给你相反的东西，你知道，比如我和安吉拉的友谊就是一段治愈的友谊。你知道，这只是一种无条件爱、信任和支持的友谊，所有这些，它每天都在治愈我。我太喜欢了。但是，你知道，正如你所说，闪亮的对象是，哦，天哪，回到我早期的约会生活中。我是说，我会有多大程度上被，我不想说，但你知道的，就像，我确实会，不是正确的人，因为那很熟悉，但那并不是最健康的。对。你们都关注罗姆尼医生吗？她是一位医生，她做了很多关于自恋和童年创伤之类的工作。其中一件事是，她在自己的播客上请了一位嘉宾，对方说，
what is the number one sign of an adult struggling or an adult who has survived childhood trauma? And he said, without skipping a beat, he said, it's trying to make difficult people like you. And I thought, like, that really resonated with me. Like, when I look at some of the friendships that I've had in my life that have not worked out or that have ended disastrously, it's because I look at the fact that, like, they were difficult and they didn't like me or whatever. And I, it made it my mission to make them like me. and then ultimately it falls apart.
成年人挣扎或经历过童年创伤的头号标志是什么？他不假思索地说，那就是试图让难对付的人喜欢你。我想，这真的引起了我的共鸣。就像，当我回顾我生活中那些没有成功或以灾难告终的友谊时，那是因为我发现，她们很难对付，而且她们不喜欢我之类的事情。而我，把让她们喜欢我当作了自己的使命，最终一切都分崩离析。
But I was like, oh, my God, that's, yeah, that really spoke to me. Yeah. Are we a psychology podcast now? All of a sudden we might be. I mean, I do think to, and just to maybe wrap up this question, and something Jen and I have talked a lot about, is that there are seasons of friendship. And some people come into your life for that season.
但我当时想：哦，天哪，那是，是的，这真的触动了我。是的。我们现在是一个心理学播客了吗？突然之间我们可能真的是了。我是说，我确实认为，为了也许给这个问题作个总结，我和詹经常讨论的一件事是，友谊是有季节的。有些人来到你的生活是为了那个季节。
That's who you were at the time. That's what you needed at the time. And then they might not grow with you, right? as you grow and that's okay and the other thing is though you do have people that are going to grow with you and that's the true true friendships and I'm so thankful for my friendship with Jenna and we didn't meet as young you know we weren't teenagers you know we don't have those high school memories we didn't know each other in college we met later in life and I think that's really special too because I think sometimes you think, well, I'm too old to make a really good friend or
那时的你就是那样。那是你当时所需要的。然后随着你的成长，他们可能不会和你一起成长，对吧？随着你的成长，这也没关系。另一件事是，你确实有一些会和你一起成长的人，那才是真正的友谊。我非常感谢我和珍娜的友谊，我们相遇时并不年轻，你知道，我们不是十几岁的小姑娘，我们没有那些高中的回忆，我们在大学时并不认识彼此，我们是在人生较晚的时候相遇的，我觉得这也是非常特别的，因为有时你会想，好吧，我太老了，交不到真正的好朋友了，或者
you close yourself off to that kind of meaningful friendship. But you're not. You're not too old to make a really good friend. I love that. Did you all meet on the office? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. This is we literally met because we were the two closest women to each other. So we just had, we had a partition between us. and we would stand up. I would stand up over the partition and talk to you. Well, and Angela was also, to me, the physically closest person because the reception desk was kind of an island. But I could pass notes to Angela over the partition or between takes.
你封闭了自己，不再去寻找那种有意义的友谊。但你并没有。你并没有老到交不到真正的好朋友。我太喜欢了。你们是在《办公室》认识的吗？对。对。对。我们真的是因为我们是彼此距离最近的两个女性而认识的。所以我们只有，我们之间有个隔断。我们会站起来。我会站过隔断跟你说话。嗯，对我也一样，安吉拉在物理上是最接近我的人，因为接待台就像是一个小岛。但我可以隔着隔断或者在两场拍摄之间把纸条传给安吉拉。
I could just stand up and we could talk. But for me to talk to anyone else, it was like a literal journey. She had to come out from around the, you know, that reception desk. I'm sure you've been asked us 10 million times and have answered. this 10 million times. But was the character's name, Angela? Or did they just like, they're like, we like that name? We'll just let you use your real name. You know, basically what Greg has said was there were some new characters that didn't have
我本来可以站起来，我们就可以聊天。但如果我想和别人说话，就像是一次真正的旅行。她得从那个，你知道的，前台接待处走出来。我敢肯定你们已经被问过一千万次了，也回答过一千万次了。但那个角色的名字是安吉拉吗？还是他们只是觉得，就像，我们喜欢这个名字？我们就让你用真名吧。你知道，格雷格基本上说过的是，有一些新角色是没有名字的
names or weren't in the original BBC version of the show. And he just, in the writer's room, they were just kind of lazy and gave them our names. So it's Phyllis, Creed, Angela. Right, of course. Yeah, yeah. And it was just enough to confuse the hell out of everybody. So, great. Well, before we let you go, we have to talk about.
或者不在原版的BBC电视剧里。他只是在编剧室里有点偷懒，直接用了我们的名字。所以有菲利斯、克里德、安吉拉。对，当然。是啊，是啊。这就足以把所有人都搞糊涂了。太好了。好吧，在让我们离开之前，我们必须谈谈。
So Jen Samart is not the only stage star on this call right now because Ms. Jenna Fisher is doing a play very soon. Yeah, Ashland Avenue at the Goodman Theater. I love the Goodman. I'm so excited. My husband wrote the play. He went to school in Chicago. He went to theater school at DePaul. And this play is a real love letter to Chicago.
所以珍·萨马特并不是现在这个通话里唯一的舞台明星，因为詹娜·费舍尔小姐很快就要出演一出舞台剧了。对，古德曼剧院的阿什兰大道。我很喜欢古德曼。我太兴奋了。我丈夫写了这部剧。他在芝加哥上过学。他在德保罗大学读过戏剧学校。这部剧是对芝加哥的一封真挚的情书。
It's about a small business owner in Chicago who is kind of dealing with the fact that maybe the world doesn't want small businesses anymore in a way. Like they don't want his small business. And so he's trying to hold on to it. It's kind of a family dromedy. I play this character's daughter. But I'm so excited. I mean, I am a huge theater nerd. I texted my vocal coach today. And I read my script with my coffee. I just try to read it a couple times a week. We start rehearsals soon and then it opens in September. Oh, wonderful. And who's directing it? Susan Booth, the artistic director of the Goodman. And then Fran Geinen plays the lead. He's like a big Chicago legend. So I can't believe I get to play his daughter and it's a really
它讲述了一个芝加哥的小企业主的故事，他正在应对这样一个事实：也许世界在某种程度上不再需要小企业了。就像他们不想要他的小企业一样。所以他正努力坚持下去。这有点像家庭悲喜剧。我扮演这个角色的女儿。但我太兴奋了。我的意思是，我是一个超级戏剧迷。我今天给我的声乐教练发了短信。我和着咖啡读了我的剧本。我只是试着一周读它好几遍。我们很快就要开始排练了，然后在九月开演。哦，太棒了。谁来导演？古德曼剧院的艺术总监苏珊·布思。然后弗兰·盖宁扮演主角。他就像芝加哥的大传奇人物。所以我不敢相信我有机会演他的女儿，而且这是一个非常
great cast. Is this your first time on stage professionally? No, this will be my third time. So I got my degree in theater. So it's my first love and it's kind of all I want to do now moving forward, you know, save for like if there's some cool little movie role or something that I can sink my teeth into. But my hope is that as my kids graduate from high school, I'll move to New York and just try to make it as a theater actress. Seriously, Jen, you're her goal in life. You're her goal in life. It's true. But I can't sing and dance. I can't sing and dance. So you're not going to see me in any musicals. That's okay. Let's do a play together. We did it out of time. We did it. We did out of town in Chicago, and it's the greatest theater town, and I'm sure you're going to be wonderful and break legs. And this is thrilling. And yes. And look, New York's not going anywhere. So come on. Come on. The water's fine. Come on in. Thank you. Oh, my gosh. Jen, it's all I want to do. I'm just so excited. Yay.
棒的演员阵容。这是你第一次专业地上台表演吗？不是，这将是我的第三次。我拿到了戏剧学位。所以这是我的初恋，也是我以后想做的全部事情，你知道的，除了如果有某个很酷的小电影角色或者我可以全身心投入的东西。但我的希望是，当我的孩子们从高中毕业时，我会搬到纽约，努力成为一名戏剧女演员。说真的，珍，这就是你的人生目标。这就是你的人生目标。真的。但我不会唱歌跳舞。我不会唱歌跳舞。所以你不会在任何音乐剧里看到我。没关系。我们一起演一部剧吧。我们在外地演过。我们在芝加哥进行过外地演出，那是最好的戏剧之城，我确信你会表现得很棒，旗开得胜。这太令人兴奋了。是的。看，纽约又不会跑。所以来吧。来吧。水温正好。快下来吧。谢谢。哦，天哪。珍，这是我唯一想做的事。我太兴奋了。耶。
Steve and I are going to come and see it. No question. I can't wait. Stop it. Stop it. For sure. Okay. Well, you let me know when you come. I'm going. I'm going to go to the opening. If you're going to go, I would love to hang out with you. We could grab a drink. Oh my God. If that's it really. invitation, then that is what I'm going. Well, yeah, I'll, I'll picture. Yeah, give me your deets. I don't know what. What do we say?
史蒂夫和我一定会来看的。毫无疑问。我等不及了。别这样。别这样。肯定的。好吧。嗯，你来的时候告诉我。我要去。我要去看首演。如果你要去的话，我很想和你一起逛逛。我们可以喝一杯。天哪。如果这真的是邀请，那我就去。好吧，是的，我会，我会拍照片。把你的联系方式给我。我不知道说什么。我们说什
What do the kids say today? I don't know. Do we say deets? Well, and Angela, you have a cookbook coming out. I do. You guys, my husband is amazing cook. He's a phenomenal baker and just an amazing chef. And he's self-taught.
么？现在的孩子们怎么说？我不知道。我们说联系方式吗？对了，安吉拉，你要出一本食谱。是的。伙计们，我丈夫是个了不起的厨师。他是个非凡的烘焙师，也是个了不起的厨师。而且他是自学成才的。
And it's really just, I think, a gift that he had within him because I don't know how he's so good at everything, like from cookie decorating to takes to, you know, one pot dinners. The man is just a natural in the kitchen. But he really wanted to do a cookbook because something he has really helped me and the kids with is not being afraid to try to cook and get in there. And I was always like, I can't cook. I can't cook. And he'd be like, you can. And it's where we really fell in love was in our kitchen. I mean, just over a meal together. We met later in life. You know, we were divorced with kids. And that's the heart of our was the kitchen. And so we've been cooking together. We did some YouTube videos. And, you know,
这真的只是，我认为是他内在的一种天赋，因为我不知道为什么他什么都那么擅长，从饼干装饰到牛排，再到，你知道的，一锅端晚餐。这个男人在厨房里就是个天才。但他真的很想出一本食谱，因为他真正帮助我和孩子们的一件事，就是不怕尝试去烹饪并参与其中。我总是说，我不会做饭。我不会做饭。而他会说，你能行。我们真正坠入爱河的地方其实就是在我们的厨房里。我的意思是，就是在一顿饭的时光里。我们年纪稍长时才相遇。你知道的，我们都是离异带娃。而我们的核心就是厨房。所以我们一直在一起做饭。我们拍了一些YouTube视频，然后，你知道的，
we've been out there for a while, bacon with Josh and Ange, because my family calls me Ange, Jen, so you can call me Ange. You can call me Angie and Patrick. Bacon with Josh and Ann. That's the name of the cookbook? That's sort of our YouTube and our Instagram and all of that. But that is what led years and years of us cooking together and making all these recipes. And he, He has so many great recipes that he has tweaked and made his own. And the cookbook is called You Can Make This. Because that's what he always says to.
我们做这个已经有一段时间了，“和乔希与安吉一起烘焙”，因为我的家人叫我安吉，珍，所以你也可以叫我安吉。你可以叫我安吉和帕特里克。“和乔希与安吉一起烘焙”。食谱的名字是这个吗？这有点像我们的YouTube、Instagram和所有这些平台。但正是这些年复一年我们一起做饭并制作所有这些食谱的经历促成了这一点。他，他有那么多很棒的食谱，经过他不断的调整并打上了他自己的烙印。这本食谱的名字叫《你可以做到》。因为那是他总是对……
I love that. I'm going to do this. I'm going to learn to cook. That's like my big dream. You had me at one pot dinners. Yes. I don't have a lot of time. There's like a one sheet.
我太喜欢了。我要这样做。我要学做饭。这就像是我的终极梦想。你用“一锅端晚餐”吸引了我。是的。我没有很多时间。就像是一页纸的食谱。
Okay. One pot. One sheet. Mm-hmm. Yeah. And soups. Oh, yeah. He loves a soup.
好吧。一锅端。一页纸。嗯哼。是的。还有汤。哦，是的。他超爱做汤。
And it's just, it's really accessible, easy recipes that are really delicious. and the food photography, like, you know, we always just take pictures ourselves. And we hired this gal, Victoria Harris. The book is so beautiful. So I could not anticipate that. I'm like, oh, my God, this is so beautiful. And it's coming out in October. So October 22nd, guys.
而且，这真的是那些平易近人、简单易做而且非常美味的食谱。食物摄影，就像，你知道的，我们总是自己拍照。我们雇了这个女孩，维多利亚·哈里斯。这本书太美了。所以我完全没想到。我说，哦，天哪，这也太美了吧。它将在十月出版。所以是10月22日，伙计们。
But you can pre-order now. You can pre-order now. Oh, there it is. Pre-order now. We will. We will. We will. Oh, my God.
但你现在就可以预订。你现在就可以预订。哦，就是这样。现在就预订。我们会订的。我们会订的。我们会订的。哦，天哪。
Thank you. Well, Angela and Jenna, we love you so much. This has been a dream since. before we even launched. So thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you for doing this. Thank you for having us. I don't want to leave. I don't want to leave.
谢谢。好吧，安吉拉和詹娜，我们太爱你们了。这甚至在我们开播之前就是一个梦想。所以谢谢你们，谢谢你们，谢谢你们，谢谢你们来做客。谢谢你们邀请我们。我不想离开。我不想离开。
I love you guys. Will you come back and do it again? Sure. Absolutely. Well, you know, who knows, Patrick? Maybe when we actually get to the Barbara Thundek episode, I have a feeling Jenna took notes and did her homework. Did you do homework?
我爱你们。你们会再来做客吗？当然。绝对会。好吧，你知道的，谁知道呢，帕特里克？也许当我们真正讲到芭芭拉·邓代克那一集时，我有一种感觉，詹娜做了笔记，还做好了家庭作业。你做作业了吗？
I took notes too. She did. So maybe, so maybe, so season three. I reached out to your team and I was like, I don't want them to feel like they have to take notes. We can't help our selves. We couldn't help our own. Dorothy and Rose did their homework.
我也记笔记了。她做了。所以也许，所以也许，第三季。我联系了你们的团队，我说，我不想让他们觉得他们必须做笔记。我们控制不住自己。我们情不自禁。桃乐丝和罗斯做了功课。
So maybe for the Barbara Doris, the actual episodes, it's not far from now. We could, is it season four? Season three. It's coming up soon. It's coming up. I think it's season three episode 50. Yeah. Yeah.
所以也许对于芭芭拉·多丽丝，实际的剧集，离现在不远了。我们可以，是第四季吗？第三季。快到了。快到了。我想是第三季第50集。对。对。
I have more thought. Get a little tea there. I'm coming to your show. You can't keep me away. I hope you are. And we're getting the book. And you're going to get an email today. Jen, I can't wait to see you on stage.
我有更多的想法。在那儿喝点茶。我要去看你的演出。你挡不住我。我希望你会来。我们要买这本书。你今天会收到一封邮件。珍，我等不及在舞台上看到你了。
My gosh. Yes. Let me know. me know, and we'll say hi. You come up to the dressing room. Oh, my God, that would be amazing. All right. You guys, thank you so much.
天哪。是的。让我知道。让我知道，我们会打招呼的。你来化妆间找我。哦，天哪，那太棒了。好了。伙计们，非常感谢。
What a wonderful morning. We love you, besties for the rest of you. Yay! Bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
多么美好的早晨。我们爱你们，永远的挚友。耶！再见。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。